I'm doing foogie right now.
Hello everybody!
Hi!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Oh, we've kind of just been talking.
Limeo and Snuffy are already streaming, so...
We were just chattin'.
But yeah, I want to say hi before we get into the game.
Sorry, Doki's just talking to herself.
She loves to hear herself speak.
And he's like...
What is she talking about?
What the hell is she saying?
Are you okay?
I'm so tired.
I literally just woke up.
But we will be using the in-game audio.
We're just in Discord for now.
I can't judge anybody.
I woke up at like 5.31 today.
Okay.
A long time ago?
I am...
Not starting stream yet.
Oh my god!
You're like, hey guys!
Hey guys!
I'm so ready!
I'll host Adabi.
Okay!
Let me host it real quick.
I can't remember, Mint.
Do you have like a stand-in account on Twitch that I can tag?
I don't even remember if you do.
I know Doki has one.
Oh!
Alright, I'm going...
You're live right, Mint?
If you don't want me to tag you, I'll just say, and Mint.
I don't remember what it is.
Hold on, let me go to Twitch.
Alright.
I'm inviting friends right now.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
I went straight in.
Oh my god!
Wait!
Someone's streaming!
Oh my god, sorry.
Oh, no intro.
No intro.
I've been live this whole time.
This is me, Limu.
Okay, Stephanie.
What is it?
Okay.
It's a real account.
I promise.
Super real.
Totally legit.
Oh, you sent the thing.
I got it.
Yeah, I sent it.
Oh wait!
It says invited you, but it doesn't show up.
Like, there's no like, join.
No, same.
There's no join?
Yeah.
Oh shit, then can you join my lobby just through the thing?
I'll see if I can.
It says you're playing VTube Studio.
I don't know if you're updating the game.
Oh, that's a thing.
Wait, how do you change how you look at?
Because you don't run the non-Steam version of VTube Studio?
I do run without Steam.
No, I run without Steam.
But instead it now tells me that I'm playing V Bridger.
Oh!
Oh, yes.
Oh, I didn't know you could do it without Steam.
I am.
Yeah, it's apparently less performance intensive.
You just...
You have to do it like on the...
You can do it for V Bridger too.
Oh!
Yeah, the file.
It's like on the...
You open where the file is and you just click the .ex file.
Oh!
There's one thing.
You click like, open file location?
And then you'll see like, VTube Studio.
And then it'll be like, VTube Studio without Steam.
Yeah.
That's basically it, yeah.
How do you change what you look like?
I don't want to be green.
Oh, look at your passport.
Do you have a tangent at the airport?
Are you really in line?
How do I get in?
Yeah, how do I get in?
Let me in.
Give me a sec.
I'm customizing my character.
Let us in!
I'm gonna miss my flight!
I can't join Donkey because she's playing VTube Studio.
Give me a sec.
She's staying from the mirror and changing her outfit.
I'll show myself online.
You are already online.
It just says you're playing VTube Studio.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm doxxing myself.
Give me a sec.
How do you guys see it?
Everything is private.
I don't know.
Clearly, there's a security breach.
Oh, there is.
You guys are preaching my security right now.
Oh, man!
Alright, here we go.
You guys should be able to see game details.
And then I'll invite people now.
Invite people now.
Yeah, now I'll invite people.
I invited...
Lamu.
I invited Mint.
Nah, it's the same thing.
I'm still seeing VTube Studio.
It looks like this.
Okay, I'm gonna reboot the game.
I'll reboot the game.
I can never remember what order you're supposed to open stuff up in to make that work properly.
Wait, there's an order?
I didn't know that either!
Yeah, it's because it's like one game will supersede the other.
I think it's the one you do first, which is annoying.
But maybe if you add VTube Studio to your private games.
Like if it was like an illicit creepy format or something.
I'm learning so much right now.
I don't want to.
Oh my god.
I don't want people to know I'm a VTuber.
Like if you were ashamed to be playing VTube Studio or something.
Like I don't want anyone to know I'm a VTuber.
Personal confession.
Can I have...
Can I also blast a game to everybody so that they know that I'm playing?
Yes.
I don't want everyone to know you're playing orc massage.
You've never been like the victim of somebody booting up like Skyrim's grip extender like 500 times?
You know like old YouTube montage videos in the bottom right corner?
You'll see such and such has begun playing Team Fortress 2.
Over and over again.
Yay, I got the invite.
Okay.
Yes, I had to boot in.
Oh, I got it too!
Okay, bye.
Failed to find Lobby.
Okay, well, that's on you.
Okay.
Mint.
Oh, I got it.
Alright.
Snuffy, what is...
Are you not inviting me?
Wait, are you not just...
Are you not called Snuffy?
What the fuck is your name on Steam?
I'm...
It's Snum?
Snum?
Who the fuck is Snuffy?
Snum.
Okay, there is no Snum on my foot.
Are you up here?
I see you!
I'm gonna message you.
Hello?
You're up.
Hello, I am here.
Hello!
Invite.
I'm muting everybody in Discord.
I fucking love how it just blasts everyone's volume in this goddamn game.
Everyone is so peaky.
It's awful.
Oh.
Yes, get online or you're not going on vacation with us.
You're gonna be left behind on a sloppy vacation.
You're gonna be left behind?
How do I use my passport?
Oh, left click.
Oh, left.
I'm muting myself.
I'm putting myself on, though, now.
Oh, wow, I can customize myself.
Snum has joined!
Remember to, like, instead...
Instead of deafen, to just, like, un-deafen and turn us down so we can still see your feet.
Oh, yay.
But you have to promise not to...
So we'll know they're alive or not.
Yeah.
You have to promise not to actually turn me back up because I'm gonna be talking to my chat and I'm gonna be talking mad shit and it'd be awkward if you heard it.
Exactly.
Alright, now.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna put on my makeup.
I gotta change myself.
Wait.
Which one should I?
Should I be Donald Duck or should I be...
Give me a sec.
I gotta be angry.
This is a serious game for serious gamers.
I'll have to be Charlie Brown.
Maybe Charlie Brown.
Wait.
Which way around are you doing?
You're muting everyone else, right?
Yeah.
I'm turning everyone else down but I'll still see the foogies.
I can't wait for like in four months from now when we do another game via Discord and we can't figure out why we're trying to make it again.
That's always fun.
Yeah.
That's me.
That's how I feel right now.
Whoa.
Your stance.
I've never played this game.
Actually, I've never played this game.
I haven't watched anyone play this game.
I don't know anything about what's going on.
I've watched people play this game.
It's going to be very exciting.
But...
I haven't...
I haven't like played it myself.
I waited till this very moment to play this game.
Me too!
The first sloppy experience?
Yeah!
That's amazing.
Did you two play it yet or no?
I played it when it came out.
So if we can be like...
Snuffy and I can be like the tour guides.
Okay.
Alright.
You're so mad.
Wait, this is like...
All of us.
This is so good.
Press R for emo.
This is how I feel.
No!
Wait, you have glasses.
Yeah.
I'm cool.
How did you get glasses?
How do I take...
Oh, there we go.
Snuffy, if you've been talking, we can't hear you.
It's not that we don't love you and we're ignoring you or anything.
It's literally we can't hear you.
You're just kind of Dreamworks facing at us silently.
Yeah, it's actually really freaky.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hello?
You're talking now.
What...
How are you...
Dead?
Ew!
Okay, there we go.
We can hear you now.
Yeah, we can hear you.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Sunglasses.
I want sunglasses.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Don't take my glasses.
I played this game a little bit.
I played it and I got really obsessed with trying to like...
eat it.
Because I thought it was like a cozy game.
And then I realized that it's a game of nothing but trials and tribulations.
It's not cozy?
No, apparently it's not cozy.
No.
Wait, can I practice you?
It's quite stressful.
Wait, Sunglasses.
You're being quiet.
Can you turn up...
Is it possible to turn up people's volumes in game right now?
Uh, yeah.
Hit escape.
Is this better?
Although...
Oh, Jesus Christ!
No!
Keep your own volume!
Holy fuck!
What happened?
Okay, um...
I'll turn you up on my end.
It's okay.
Keep your own volume.
Oh my God.
Okay, okay.
I'm deaf.
Wait, how could he...
He's under here.
Alright, I'm ready.
How do you turn up individual people?
Uh, hit escape.
Top right corner.
Press escape.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
I have to turn everyone down to like 30%.
Otherwise, I'd go fucking deaf in this game.
It's not that loud on my end.
Yeah, me neither.
Yeah, you guys sound great.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
Do you wish to know how to climb?
Yes, how do you guys?
Oh!
Oh, there's a trial!
I didn't realize.
Wait, there's a rope!
Oh, look at her go!
I'm just gonna skip ahead.
Here we go!
I'm ready!
Cowabunga, dude!
I'm ready for my vacation!
Oh, okay.
And the big thing that you can do is when you're on like top of a cliff, if you right click, you hold out your arm and you lift your friends up.
Oh!
Like that.
Yeah.
Wait, what do you do?
You just hold out your hand?
I've got your...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, right click and you like lift people up.
Oh, right click.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you literally don't have to...
Oh, look!
No!
Wait, did you just push her off?
No, she fell.
She fell off.
Jake.
There's actually a mod where you can push people off, too.
That's fucked up.
I wanna play that mod.
That's like the PvP edition.
Do the rocks not matter?
I'm just climbing.
I wish I got the Mount Everest mod.
No, you can climb any surface except if it's raining and then you'll take more.
It's worth pointing out now, but the game doesn't tell you so you can get fucked.
No, there's fall damage!
Just not here.
There is fall damage.
Guys, it's fine.
There's no fall damage.
Yeah, see?
Wee!
I'm okay!
Yeah, definitely.
You should definitely get straight into the game and jump off a cliff.
It'll be fine.
Okay!
Yay!
I'll catch your phone.
That's what my tour guide told us.
Thank you.
You know, like, yesterday I was watching videos of, like, um, uh, freakiest cave-climbing depths and everything.
Oh my God, that's- Are you gonna live that today?
And then they are talking- cave diving, so they are like- cave diving, you know, like, those we'd dive even like- We know what- what?
Cave- Cave-divers, people who go into caves and they start diving.
Yeah, and they start diving in caves, you know?
They just like, spin stuff!
Yeah, you know, caves, caves, caves?
They dive?
They're called cave divers.
They live in those caves and they also dive too.
That's why it's called cave divers.
That's like crazy.
Oh my god, we didn't even hear what happened yet.
We only knew that they were cave diving.
Yeah, I'm talking about cave diving.
You know what that is?
No, I don't know.
Tell me.
Okay, so it's like you go in a cave and you like dive in the cave.
And that's like water and that's why I have to dive.
It's like sometimes people die in there because they're in the water.
Wait, do they die or do they die?
Because they go into the cave and they die.
And then they die.
They should have just brought the V with them.
What the heck?
And it's gonna... Okay, so like...
And one of the incidents because of the tour guide's fault.
So like, that's what I mean.
It's gonna be all I have to die.
Wait, what the... What the... Holy shit, that was a huge detour just to blame me.
I was like, what's the point of this story?
Yeah, you like went on like a 10-minute tangent for that.
Holy moly.
I thought you were just gonna describe how you have a new fear from it or something.
It was a crazy video, though.
It was...
What was it?
The Nutty Putty Cave?
Yeah, because the tour guide was like, we should go dive in this cave.
You know, to go cave diving.
And they're like, oh, it's very dangerous.
But he's like, no, we got this.
And then every... And then everyone died.
The end.
And then everyone died.
How did you do your emotes, Adam?
You press R?
Oh, R?
Nice.
Okay, you guys can swear to tell I just woke up, right?
Yeah, that's what it's... That's what it feels like.
It has nothing on it.
Yeah.
I guess we all have little, like, Girl Scout badges.
Yeah, there's a mirror.
You gotta practice dancing.
Whoa!
Oh, no.
I think everybody's like drunk at the airport.
I don't know what's going on.
We're in one of those...
Oh, I'm silent airports.
I don't know.
Don't worry, guys.
We're gonna see the last...
Getting wasted at the Las Vegas airport.
Me?
Could it be me?
In that Firefly book.
Lord of the Flies.
What are you talking...
Get this girl a muzzle.
Shut up!
Lord of the Flies!
What is...
What is bro yapping about?
Are you ready?
I'm going to board us.
Yeah, let's board the flies.
Do we need to show our past floor?
What's happening?
Why are we like this?
I feel like I caught the stupid from Doki.
Please, caught the stupid!
We're scouts, you better shape up or we're not gonna make it.
Oh my god, we're dead?
Wait!
What happened?
It is Lord of the Flies!
I haven't seen any caves.
I told you it is Lord of the Flies!
We are the boys in the Lord of the Flies book!
I can't believe...
I thought we were going for a hike for real.
This is what this is about.
Oh my god, we're actually...
Okay, how to not die?
I'm reading the book.
Don't worry.
I can read.
How do I flip the page?
Sure.
Okay.
Day one.
Okay, okay.
I caught the fire.
Never abandon a friend in need.
Conch.
Wait, I can throw it.
The plane is still hot.
Be careful.
Oh wait, you can run!
Guys, you can run!
Hey Doki, come and touch this with your face.
Wait, where'd my...
Where'd my horn go?
What's that thing?
Figure out how to...
Is that the duolingo bird?
Towards my voice.
I don't know.
I don't know what this is.
His name is Bing Bong.
There you go.
Oh!
Bing Bong!
I'm throwing.
Ah!
Oh my god, Doki!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Does anybody know first aid?
I have no idea how that happened.
Does anyone...
What did I slip?
Oh my god!
Can someone pee out?
The man of war!
Jellyfish!
Everyone start peeing on me!
Oh!
Isn't that how you do the...
Everyone start peeing!
Everyone...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh you guys!
Somebody help!
Oh no!
Somebody help me!
Stop!
Yo!
Sick flip!
Oh no!
You did it!
Someone help me!
I'm stuck!
Sloppy!
Wait, how did you get the backpack?
Ew, there's one backpack and I took it.
You can just open it all in a pack.
You can just take what's in there.
It's not so great.
But I have a compass!
Oh nice!
Super useful!
Oh yeah!
We can just open it up!
Got us!
Oh wait, I'm getting unvoiced!
Look at the way you walked!
I'm getting hungry!
I'm gonna get a coconut!
Oh what?
Oh, coconut!
Wait, is this a survival game?
Or...
Yeah, we have to climb.
You see that big mountain in the distance?
Yeah!
You gotta get up there!
Yeah, and that's all we have to climb.
And that's...
Yeah, definitely.
Nothing after that.
How we win the game.
What's that?
Is that a crab?
Okay, there it goes.
She's grabbing the coconut.
Oh no, that's another thing that I slipped on.
She's gonna...
No!
Don't worry, I got you!
Did I get them?
Don't worry, land on us!
We got you!
She did it?
Oh, there's another one!
Oh, climb!
Climbing?
Sorry, I was trying to break up with the coconut!
I don't know!
Fuck you!
I'm eating it right now!
Okay...
I wanna eat it!
Oh, what's up?
How do you climb the tree?
I wanna be a little monkey.
Same like the...
Same as the cliff.
Oh, okay.
Climbing?
Oh, here we go.
Get the coconut when you're at the top!
I'm gonna get it!
Don't get it, Doki!
No!
It's mine!
I broke my leg.
Wait, it doesn't heal me.
No, no.
You need bandages for that.
It doesn't heal you.
Uh-oh.
You actually fell off the tree!
I live, though.
I live.
Probably because I landed on your big ass head.
That's it!
I'm climbing this other tree!
I wanna taste the sweet, sweet, succulent coconut, please!
And I have a broken leg.
I ate the other coconut, too.
Wait, there's another coconut!
There's a flying jellyfish!
Do you see that floating jellyfish?
Yeah, there's a floating fish!
As long as it's not just me.
Okay, yeah.
I think Doki hit me kinda hard with that coconut or something.
We need more coconut or we'll die!
Stop!
Well, there are other things other than coconuts.
That is unnatural!
You will see my Hello Kitty luggage anywhere.
I lost it on a flight.
What you got in your luggage, Snuffy?
Yeah.
Do demons come out at 9?
Wait, wait, this is literally like the age-old question.
Like, if you got stranded on an island, what are you taking?
The only thing is we need to stick together because if we don't, the Scoutmaster will be mad at us.
Who?
And then who do you think...
It's like, who do you think will survive on an island?
What's that?
Not me, that's for sure.
Or he broke my leg.
I found a something.
Oh, luggage!
Oh, look!
Dookie, there's food in this bush.
Oh!
We need to test it to make sure it's not poisonous, though.
Don't worry.
There's a trail mix over here and some bandages.
Oh, oh, I think...
Is that radish a heal root?
Yeah.
You guys need this.
Wait a minute, I ate this already.
It's not poisonous.
If you're hungry.
What's that?
What's that sound?
Take the medicinal root and eat it, Dookie.
You will feel better.
Oh, okay.
Cluster shroom.
This is an ancient herb.
I'm gonna feed it to you.
With medicinal properties.
I already ate it.
Oh.
Wait, am I still hungry?
Is the shrimp good?
I can hear.
Are you still hungry?
Yeah, the shrimp's good.
I already ate one.
Okay.
Excuse me, but mushrooms are really dangerous, you guys.
We should mess around.
Does this thing hurt me?
No, we have Dookie to poison test it.
I got a sports drink.
What's that sound?
Pick up.
What's the music for?
You guys?
Where are you guys?
What's the music?
Hello.
Climb?
Are we climbing?
Oh.
Hi.
Oh, can I have that?
Alright.
Where do we go?
That was really good.
Oh, thanks.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
How many people have died on this mountain?
There's so many things.
Yeah, there's so much luggage around it.
I think it's just all our luggage.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch this.
Give us a head start.
She's so nice.
Good technique.
We definitely should have used that there, yeah.
Yay!
I'm a hero, everyone.
Dookie might have broken her other leg if we didn't use that.
Is this here?
Yeah, exactly.
It's for the sake of my leg.
I'm gonna eat that.
Oh my god, yes.
And you just knew that there was more luggage.
Alright.
I'm no longer hungry.
Oh my god, wait.
I'm glad to hear it.
Oh my god.
Thanks.
Look at that.
I'm cured.
Watch that urchin, it will poison you again.
Oh, it will?
Okay, I watched it before.
I don't think this is the best route to go.
We're going like the absolute worst.
Wait, do you have space in the inventory, Snuffy?
What was that green thing?
No, I don't.
But we can put it in Lemu's backpack.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I won't put this in the backpack.
I'm grabbing it.
You gonna root around in my backpack?
Okay, be gentle.
Yeah, I got it.
I got stuck in the backpack.
I think you- someone took something out of it.
You stole my fucking drink.
I think I'm falling.
I just needed this so bad.
You're fine.
Wait, where are we supposed to go?
Up here?
Uh, there are a few different pathways.
I've not played this one yet.
I've got the lantern.
Oh, cool.
I'm probably this way.
Wait.
Wait, where- Who said that?
This way.
Oh, middle mouse button you can like point.
With your fingers.
Yeah, like this way.
Oh, really?
Wait.
Oh, cool.
Oh, what?
Oh, that's what that was!
Oh no, Tachi!
I thought she was down- I thought she- I can dig it.
How do you go down?
Oh, you just crawl like that.
I thought I can dig it.
Wait.
Guys, I'm slow.
I don't want energy up!
Okay, I need help.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Toki, I've got a remedy for you.
I'm going!
I'm climbing!
Uh-oh.
I'm going the wrong way!
I'm gonna lose energy!
You're fine, you're fine.
Grab my hand!
No, grab my hand!
My hand!
Wait, who are we asking?
Where the fuck is Snuffy?
Oh, no, she's below.
She's below.
Grab my hand!
My hand!
I'm pushing!
Don't get up!
I will push you down!
I will push you off this cliff!
Snuffy!
Grab my hand!
Come on, Snuffy!
I will push you off!
Snuffy!
Grab my hand!
And Rapunzel, let down your hair!
Grab my hand, stop me, grab my hand!
I think I'm...
Grab my hand, stop me, what happened?
Oh, God.
We're gonna make it gas.
We're gonna...
What's that mean?
That means we fucked around for so long, but the fog is already coming.
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, no.
I need a hand, someone let down the golden hand.
Wait, wait.
Someone let down the golden hand.
Look at you, wow, you got the moves.
You must stop.
Stop for your own dead queen.
Please.
Are you good?
Grab my hand.
There's nobody...
Oh, my God, Blimey, you're gonna fall.
That's so scary.
Oh, my God, that totally doesn't look like you can make it.
This looks like pro gamer moves, and I'm a newbie.
Oh, my God, my heart.
I'm okay.
It's not...
No, this is not a good route.
Did we mess up?
Should we climb down here and try a different way?
I don't know.
So, we want to look for any ledges that have this sandy texture, because that means we can climb it.
If it doesn't have the orange, then we can't, like, stand there.
So, we want to try, like, up here has, like...
There's, like, sort of...
Oh, the sand.
Whoa.
Wait, there's, like, something up here.
Do you guys see that?
Oh, yeah.
Maybe we can make that.
Okay, who is the one that makes the gun thing?
Wait, I have this.
Is this helpful?
I have this.
Okay, that's definitely not...
Okay, okay.
I got up here.
Yeah, yeah.
Let me grab your hand.
I come in.
Grab my hand.
Grab my hand instead.
You're really...
I'm too close!
Grab my hand instead!
I have an idea.
Dookie, you made it, like, halfway.
Okay, I have an idea.
Wait, is this not a dead end?
Oh.
I don't...
Maybe we should...
Oh, sorry, I forgot!
It's a dead end, you guys!
Is there nothing up there?
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, there's nothing up there.
It's a dead end.
I'm not gonna die.
I don't think you went up there.
I don't think you went that way.
I don't know.
Where'd she go?
Oh, you went this way.
Okay.
Uh...
How'd she get over there?
Not even...
Oh no, we're cave diving!
Where did Lime go?
Did she leave us?
Oh, we're back here.
No, I'm down here.
I'm here.
I'm coming to you!
Snuff!
Yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
I'm not coming to you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm scared.
This is it.
This is it for me.
Wait, I gotta do it.
I think we wanna go slightly around.
This kinda seems like...
Butts.
I don't know.
Alright, I'm gonna...
You go tell us where to go.
I didn't remember the V.
Oh, a terrible idea to do.
I'm drinking my drink.
Don't push me.
Don't do it.
None of us are doing great.
Trap my hand!
Won't you take a poor sinners hand?
I'm gonna try a different way.
I think we should come down.
Trap my hand!
Oh, look at her go!
Are you ready?
Ready!
Wait, where's Loma?
Conservation center!
Oh, she went the other way.
Why did we not go through this bridge?
Oh, be careful about this bridge!
There's nothing.
There's a bridge?
Wait, what?
Uh-oh, I'm here and echoing.
I'm climbing.
I'm climbing to you.
Over here.
Thanks.
Yeah, yeah.
Transformation Central.
Oh, are you sorry?
Can you feel it?
Are you hungry?
Oh, you're little.
Is it okay?
Yeah, yeah.
That's a good one.
Wait, where'd it go?
Totally.
I fed it to you.
I can feed it to you.
Oh, yeah, thanks.
That's kind of scary because then you can just feed people intentional poison.
It's just a little jump scare.
We should do that to Doki.
Okay, so here's what I'm thinking.
We just launch ourselves.
Okay.
Okay, let me demonstrate.
Wait, where did they go, guys?
How did you guys cave dive?
Wait, are they in there?
Wait, guys, you know what happens when you cave and dive?
You cave and die.
Oh, yeah.
Nutty putty cave.
I'm glad I brought the nutter butters to the nutty buddy.
Are you guys, like, hiding from us?
I can't tell.
They're creeping me out.
Snuffy, I'm scared.
They sound like they're, like, in a treehouse.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
They're over here.
Oh, okay, okay.
How'd you guys... We have made, like, literally no progress.
No, we haven't, actually.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my monitor died for, like, five seconds.
Oh, no.
Wait, can I walk here?
Oh, I can't.
Oh, that's good.
So I can walk here because it's sand?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Where are we going?
I thought you guys were supposed to be tour guiding us.
We just got abandoned.
Every scout for themselves in this troop.
I can't tell where the hell they are.
There's another monster.
Yeah, I see it.
We're over here.
Hello.
Thank you.
The bungle shroom.
All right, I'm climbing up.
I'm a little better now.
Has anybody sampled a bungle shroom?
Is it good?
Oh, yeah.
It was okay.
I ate that.
Hello.
Our poison...
This is a trustworthy source.
Pick up my hand.
I'm too late.
Okay.
We're climbing.
Hold my hand.
Oh, you don't want to touch my hand.
I don't.
Oh my gosh, we're actually making it up the mountain.
Oh, yay.
Laimu, thank you so much for grabbing my hand.
You're welcome.
This side of the mountain is so much better.
Why did we not go on this side of the mountain?
Why did we go the hard way?
It was not obvious.
Who chose the other realm?
We're just trying to survive weather in the elements.
I'll follow you.
I'm pulling up this way.
That's a bad thing to do.
Wait, yeah.
When did Doki start eating?
I don't know.
Wait, there's a bridge here.
Thank you.
Do not...
One at a time on the bridge.
Oh.
How do you get up there?
Just climb on it.
But wait until Doki's off.
Alternatively, you could jump up and down on it to fuck with her.
But that's kind of mean.
You would never do that, right?
No.
Wait, I'm going to do that.
Come on.
You're not even looking at us.
You don't know what's going on here.
Thank you.
I didn't do anything.
It was your fat ass that made it loose.
Maybe my butt is just way too big.
Nothing didn't sink when I was on it.
I can tell from the bottom.
I can tell when someone fucks up.
Okay, you'll have to hear it.
I'm going up this pole.
Take my hand, Doki.
Take my hand.
I don't think I'm going to make it, actually.
I don't know where you are.
Here.
I'm going to drop a mushroom.
I hope it helps you somehow.
Oh.
Ouch.
I'm okay.
Uh, there might be a spot on the side here.
I could have made it if I had a little snack.
I got my arm down.
Uh, come up here.
Alright.
Yeah, this way.
What's that sound?
I'm coming up.
I need a hand.
I'm coming.
My turn.
No!
Are you ever turning your back on Doki Bear?
Oh, I see.
I see.
It's okay.
She's got iron fever.
She's going to kill us all.
I can't believe she would try and murder me.
That's fucked up.
I'm going to try and get some food.
Niches get stitches removed today.
Keep your eyes open today.
Peace and love.
I don't know if I'll make it.
Never mind, I give up.
Oh, you're following.
I don't know what you did.
Oh, I believe in this.
You do?
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, no, no, no.
Oh.
I already started.
Oh, I made it!
How?
Maybe I'm so good at this game.
Bungal Shroom.
Yummy, yummy.
On my tummy.
Bungal Shroom.
I've never met anyone as nice as you.
Where are you guys at?
I'm heading down.
I should be going up.
Because that's the game.
I'm climbing all on my own.
I think I'll make it.
There's some...
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
I didn't...
I didn't take any damage.
How did that happen?
I'll make it this time.
You think?
I didn't take any damage.
Oh my god.
Maybe actually I go...
Maybe...
Maybe I go...
I'm scared.
Ah!
Maybe it's better I'm not there.
Okay, alright, alright.
Here we go, here we go, here we go!
I'm so close, I'm so close!
We have to do it together!
Oh, I made it!
I think... am I here?
I'm here.
I'm standing.
This is not gonna... I don't think I can make it.
Help me!
Wait, Mint!
Oh my god, you've been beneath me this whole time.
Yeah, I was there, struggling for my afterlife.
Lime never made it.
Lime is... Lime, I hear her, yeah.
No, she didn't.
Lime would never.
She's our tour guide.
She's gone, guys.
I'm waiting for you, where the fuck did you go?
I don't know where you are.
Wait, what do you mean waiting?
I think we're above you.
No, I think...
Yeah, we're above you.
No, you're not.
Let's go to this bridge.
Right here.
Let's go here.
Wait, it's getting kind of foggy, no?
I'm having some disability.
It's getting a little dark over here.
Um... Yeah, this area is very, very foggy.
No, I think it's fine.
This seems very safe.
I'm gonna go up.
I will come back towards my voice.
I think I can see the bridge, and you're going towards the edge of the map.
There's a... Oh.
Oh.
Is that bad?
Um... I'm gonna go on the bridge.
You're not productive.
Ow.
Okay, I'm on the bridge.
I'm going this way.
Oh, this way.
Oh, I see you!
I see you!
There's another... Hi!
Hello!
I'm climbing on this bridge, too!
I'm already gone.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm heading up.
Wait, why am I not recovering stamina?
Up here.
Wait, there it is.
Slow.
Stop!
Move!
I'm trying to recover stamina!
I'm gonna hand up for you.
Okay.
Thank you!
Oh, the fog is coming.
We need to boogie.
Snuffy, you coming?
It's really, it's really bad.
Take my hand!
Okay, or not.
Fine, whatever.
I literally took your hand!
Um, um, where's Snuffy?
Snuffy!
Oh, Jesus!
Hey!
Oh, I see you!
He just like fell out of the sky.
What's up?
Take my hand!
You yell, take my hand, and then take your hand away?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
That's...
Uh, this way is pretty good.
Oh, nice!
Oh, wow!
It's actually so clear!
The middle-aged uncle at the family gathering that keeps like being like, you got something on your shirt!
Full champ!
I'm the boy scout where the parents were like, this...
Join the boy scout will definitely change her behavior for the better!
Alright!
You're like, instead of sending her to Juvie, we could just send her to the boy scout.
Donkey!
Fuck you!
Wait, how do we do this?
I'm gonna fall here.
Just jump!
It's a leap of faith!
Okay, I'm coming!
Oh, I'm not up!
I'm coming!
I got a hand up!
You can do it!
Yeah!
I did!
You did it!
Oh, I see.
Snuffy!
Okay, there you go.
I'm so heavy!
I'm sorry!
You kinda almost got physicsed there.
That was weird.
I'm starving.
Oh, me too.
I'm good.
Wait.
Oh, I just ate something bad.
Oh, I'm dying.
Oh, it was poisonous.
You'll be fine.
It's a temporary death.
Okay.
You look fine.
Do I?
I like temporary death.
I feel...
I feel pale.
Maybe you're taking psychic damage.
You're great.
Oh, there's a suitcase over there.
Oh, there's a suitcase!
Yeah!
Don't eat those berries!
There's a flying rock in the sky!
Wait, there's a coconut!
There's a coconut!
That's known as the sun.
Oh...
There's a coconut!
Alright, someone else go out of this tree, because I know I'm not good at that.
Okay, if you climb it, you can throw the coconut at everybody else.
Oh, that's true!
Yep.
I gotta give her the incentive to do it.
You can maybe climb this first and then jump onto the tree.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
What else is around here?
Trick shot, trick shot.
Who's gonna caught me?
You just don't land on the giant spike.
Uh, yeah, catching is definitely a thing that I can do.
Wait, I saw another suitcase.
Okay.
Watch this.
Oh!
Okay.
You got this, bro.
You got this.
Knock him down, knock him down.
Yes!
Got one!
Oh!
I did it, though.
I did it.
Okay.
Cool.
I did it, though.
We're actually getting there.
Wait, you guys need to cope for now.
We're making it!
I can see the claw!
I can get another one.
You can already?
We're in it!
Yeah, look!
There's smoke!
It's endgame!
We're in endgame!
That's definitely the end of the game!
Wow!
We're gonna command a new world record right here.
I see mushrooms.
Oh, there's bees!
There's apples!
There's lots of food here.
How did a dead jellyfish get all the way up here?
What the fuck?
I don't know if those mushrooms are okay.
The fog.
Was the tide really that crazy?
Wait, I'm hungry.
Cluster shroom!
I will take one for the team!
I'm hungry too, but fine!
Eat your fuckin' mushroom...
Crisberry, whatever it is.
It's fine.
I'm gonna have a marshmallow.
The mushroom is fine!
Oh my god, we are getting mushroom...
Marshmallows.
Yeah, marshmallows.
You don't even know which one you're talking about.
Oh, it's not fine, actually.
The mushroom is not okay.
I'm so fine.
Oh, no.
Okay.
You can eat one, but you definitely can't eat two!
Oh, wow.
I'm really taking a lot of damage.
Are you okay?
Wait.
Um...
Wait, I'm taking like a lot of...
Wait.
Holy shit.
Are you good?
I don't...
Where's...
Where's Snuffy?
Where is Snuffy?
Help me!
Snuffy?
Oh, I made it.
Okay, there she is.
What the fuck are you all the way over there?
How did she get up there?
Look at her, she's right over here.
Whoa, everything's going kind of dark.
She's like right over here.
Ah, Doki, can you take Min?
I can't take her in the backpack.
Sure.
Uh, you wanna do it quick?
Otherwise she'll cross and die.
This is good.
I can eat my sandwich.
I don't sense your urgency here.
I didn't know you could actually die.
Oh.
She's gonna let me...
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, Doki.
That's just fucked up.
I should just press E now, huh?
Don't worry, Snuffy will bring her back up.
Yep.
It's just awful.
What kind of sandwich do you enjoy, baby?
A classic.
The fuck, hella physics?
Wait, how is she gonna come back last?
Um...
We need like health.
Oh, look at that!
Where did Snuffy go?
I don't know.
Snuffy!
My death stopped going down.
If you're gonna get...
Can you take the backpack here?
Yeah, I can take it.
How do you carry it?
Oh!
Oh, you're alive!
Nevermind!
Welcome back!
What happened to me?
You did it!
I'm a little woozy.
You got poisoned.
I have no stamina, all poison, baby.
Here's your bugle.
Thank you!
You're welcome.
If you play that, something good might happen.
Snuffy!
How did you manage to end up all the way over there?
And then all the way over there and never reach here?
Oh, that's actually impressive.
The 20th Century Fox...
Oh, Mint kinda died, so I had to pick Mint up.
She looks good to me.
I definitely died.
She temporarily died.
I have no stamina, so it's hard for me to climb anything.
I found good mushrooms.
No!
No, please.
Sorry.
They're good, I promise.
No, it's okay.
No, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
I think I know what might have happened.
Whoa!
There's some marshmallows!
Yeah.
Oh, is this Outer Wild?
There's a chain marshmallow.
Uh...
Yeah.
Kidding.
I got a morale boost.
Snuffy, can you hold the chain launcher?
Whoa!
Does anybody want to eat mushrooms?
No, that's a bad mushroom.
I'm kidding.
Oh, drop it.
I thought it was pretty good.
Oh, day four!
We made it!
Yippee!
Wait, what's this?
There's a little man up here.
Oh, and a scroll.
What's a chain launcher?
Dear Diary.
Bad news!
Launching the chain.
The ship captain made an oopsie, and we've wound up crashing on this mysterious island.
Thankfully, mysterious islands are my specialty.
With our whole troop working together, we'll reach the top of the peak and signal for help in no time.
In the meantime, I'll take this opportunity to add some additional pages to my famous guidebook.
Scoutmaster Myers.
Whoa!
Scoutmaster Myers must have definitely lived, right?
Wait, I thought...
Did you all cook your marshmallow?
I thought you were the scoutmaster.
Uh, that's a different scoutmaster.
What does it do if we touched the ancient statue?
That is how you revive your friends.
Oh, like this.
Wait, I need...
That's it.
And it makes a horcrux, right?
Oh!
I got a fairy lantern?
Those are good.
Oh, it's a revive thing, right?
It heals you.
Is anyone damaged?
I have poison.
Uh, poison?
I don't know if it heals poison.
Oh, it is.
Yeah, it's healing me.
Yay!
What is my electricity bar?
Oh, that's your extra stamina.
The fairy likes me.
Oh, did you just drink the sports drink?
No, someone fed me that mushroom.
Who was it?
Oh my God.
I didn't have one.
Who was the mushroom?
It was you, wasn't it?
I know it was you.
No, it wasn't.
It wasn't me.
I wanted the good mushroom.
I promise.
I didn't mean it.
I promise I'm a vegan.
I'm getting you to the class.
No!
Wait.
You're also taking damage, Snuffy.
Did you eat the mushroom too?
I think Snuffy is eating poisonous mushrooms for fun.
I don't know.
It's everybody.
She's trying to be so helpful.
I'm just poisoning her friends.
That's who tried to poison me earlier!
Okay.
All in favor.
All in favor voting Snuffy.
Say aye.
Aye!
We both snuffy off the island!
Take your tiki torch and leave the island!
If that's what you want, I'll just jump!
No!
That's so cool!
Don't do it!
Do it!
That's right!
Did she jump?
What did you do?
I did.
Yeah, that's right.
She did.
It was a unanimous vote.
My move.
Wait, where is she?
Is she down...
Oh shit!
What?
Oh my god, my monitor died so I thought I died.
Is she down there?
Oh, I see her!
She's alive.
Oh yeah, sorry.
No, I'm good.
I thought you were like...
For the minute you were Blair witching or some shit.
That was awful.
I don't like that.
It's scary.
Just staring at the wall.
Wait, what can we...
You guys are going crazy but I'm like Cabin in the Woods level snapping.
What do we grab onto here?
I'm scared.
Okay, so when there's a little bit of a drop, you can actually turn and face the wall and like just grab it in increments when you're dropping down to stop your fall.
Oh!
What is this magic bean?
Is it good?
Oh my god, why not magic?
Oh that looks good.
Yeah.
Tell me more about your magic bean, Dosey.
Don't feed it to me.
The beans the fruit that makes you toot.
How do you give it to people?
There's like a little children's round about magic bean.
Don't tell her.
Chat, don't tell her.
I can't do anything with this magic bean.
It just says it's magic.
Oh, plant it.
Oh, I can plant it?
Okay, we gotta find a place for me to plant this magic bean.
Why does the magic bean have to do anything for you?
Do you hate whimsy?
Perhaps it's just magical.
Oh, why'd you draw?
Oh!
Whoa!
I made that!
I'm a father!
Dude!
Oh, I get it!
Oh, it's like James and the Giant Peach or something.
Yeah!
James and the Giant fucking Drill.
I should've saved that magic bean.
Wait, there's a red suitcase over there!
Yeah, I see it.
Wait, are we supposed to keep going up again?
Or is this...
Red means good.
Yeah, we're going up there.
I love the last one.
Wait, you missed that one for the round.
I don't trust...
Ouch!
I didn't even do anything.
Uh-huh.
Here I go.
I can't eat it.
Why not?
I saw this suitcase.
Yeah.
What's in there?
Min, I'm gonna feed you something and it's actually good for you.
I promise.
What is that?
Come on, it's a yellow crispery.
It's good for you.
Anyway.
Yummy!
Is it...
Supposed to be foggy?
Or...
Oh, not anymore.
Just kidding.
Um...
I mean, the fog's gonna creep up pretty quick.
I don't know where the fuck Doki went.
We better just abandon her in my head.
Doki!
Oh, I see you!
I see you!
Abandoning her would have to be an active thing.
If she wanders off, that's her fault.
Oh my god!
She's...
She's all the way up there.
Dang.
Oh, there's some good apples over here.
We don't wanna look into these apples.
Are you sure they're good?
Are you sure?
Oh!
Ah!
Are you okay?
I...
I did...
I did not realize that that's what that was.
What is this?
I don't know.
I was wondering you couldn't eat it.
And I just tried to drop it on the floor and it like...
Got really big.
Well, I just wasted that.
Let's get up here.
Cool.
Let's go!
Oh, it's a...
It's a platform.
I'm getting the apples.
You have to get up here.
We're coming!
Let's see, Minto!
I'm coming!
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
I got it.
You just belly flopped your way up there?
That was cool.
Yeah, I'd do that.
That's my technique.
The signature...
Minto...
Belly flop.
I have a cell phone that's apparently an extra platform.
Like the magic bee.
Bananas!
Isn't anybody hungry?
I don't...
Uh...
Only a little bit.
Yeah, I'm only a little.
Eat cheese.
Can we touch the spikes or...
I think I do.
Oh, cool!
No, you can't.
There's...
They are...
Very poisonous.
Did you test it with your face?
Yeah, I did.
Why are you always poison mint?
Stop putting things in your mouth!
Stop eating!
I'm like a baby!
My new son.
I'm so helpful.
Do you think these bananas are safe?
Yeah, they're bananas.
They have to be.
Uh...
Yeah.
Oh...
It's weird that there's no more monkeys on this island, but I think it's not because of the bananas.
No...
This one is actually safe.
Here you go.
It made me hungry.
No, it didn't.
Oh, I'm up here now.
It made me hungry for seconds.
She's my head!
I'm...
Uh-oh!
Oh!
I'm okay!
Oh, okay!
No, you don't!
Oh, lie to me!
Don't lie to me!
You can't believe it's gonna be poison either!
Scout members!
Be careful!
I don't know what you did stuff here.
Watch out for the spikes!
You'll get poison just like me!
The rain makes it harder to climb.
Um...
Wait, really?
No, it doesn't.
We'll just have to...
The Breath of the Wild is how it does.
You can use my stamina.
I wanna try a banana.
Alright, fine.
Climb in the rain.
See what I care.
Wow, I can't believe we came from all the way over there.
I know, right?
We did that.
We've grown so much.
We're climbing the scenic waterfall.
I know!
Oh my god, if only our Scoutmaster could see us now.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, thanks.
We got you.
Going up!
I thought this game was supposed to be scary.
You guys said.
Guys, I'm getting poisoned.
How am I...
Thank you!
You touched the poison ivy!
Don't touch poison ivy, guys.
Scouting 101, man.
Rock rises.
I thought scouting 101 was don't dropkick your teammates off the mountain.
That's the only reason why I haven't done it.
I think that's like personal respect.
Which way should we go?
Where did Doki go?
Is there a pause there where Doki went?
I guess.
Let's have a look.
Ooh!
Beautiful!
You just wanted to take me behind the romantic waterfall.
With the delicious looking plants.
I didn't want you to miss these beautiful views.
Don't fall.
We weren't.
You want this banana?
Oh!
Thank you!
Oh, I have a banana peel now.
Wait.
Can...
Watch her slip on it.
How do I drop it?
Oh, here we go.
Hey, take a step forward.
Oh, shit.
I got her side.
Wow!
I think we gotta maneuver our way through here.
Uh... I don't know if you can, actually.
Don't touch me!
Stop!
I'm feeling pressured!
Stop touching me!
Are you pointing again?
No, no, I'm okay!
Oh, wait!
Yeah, that actually worked, but I fucked it up.
And then I broke my leg again.
Doki, go back the way you went.
This way here.
And then you can walk most of the way along here when it's not raining.
Not in the rain.
How do I take it?
How do I take your apple?
What?
Take it?
Oh, and I can walk?
What?
Yeah, kind of shove yourself with the right side so you...
Whoa, what's that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can...
I'm okay.
Uh, I'm getting poisoned.
You might have just set off a giant poison explosive cloud.
Uh, I don't have...
You're poisoned!
There, I got you, I got you.
I'm coming!
Help me!
Are you okay?
I'm okay!
I got you!
This game has me hearing, like, actual screams of fear from you guys.
I don't have meds.
Oh, I have this.
I got you.
I'm being healed right now.
Wait for Doki, she needs it too.
Oh.
No, I don't think I will wait.
Okay.
Stop it!
Let us go!
I'm coming.
Min, Min.
Yeah?
Don't climb it.
Try not to climb it.
What you want to do...
No!
Um, I was already climbing when you told me not to climb it, so...
I don't really know what to tell you there.
No!
You can walk.
Just push yourself into the corner.
Walk along it.
Okay.
Okay!
Tell the clouds to friggin' climb.
Oh!
Okay, I'm climbing now.
Help me!
I made it to a new location!
Got you.
Can you bring up the cherry lantern now?
Holy shit.
Oh, it's empty.
Oh my god.
Keep...
You fucking did keep...
No, I'm going to...
No!
You're not getting upset!
Oh, now it's actually empty!
It's actually empty!
Dookie's dog is like, Don't fight!
Tell your dog to shut up!
No!
Help me!
Your dog says no violence!
He just wants to see us survive!
I'm making an example out of you.
He knows what I wanted to do.
Run!
He wants food.
And I want food, too.
Yeah, you have an apple in your backpack, okay?
You can eat.
That's not an apple.
Wait, don't touch that.
This is...
Yeah, don't touch that.
Don't touch that.
What is that?
Maybe you should touch it and find out.
Yeah, do.
Go, go.
I'll throw this, and it'll activate.
Oh, fuck!
Nice girl.
Good job, nice girl.
Don't worry.
I'm dying like that.
I don't think... I hope we didn't need that.
I got a weak look out of them, too.
I wanna go dig in this hole and find it.
I'm sure he fell somewhere in this hole.
It'll be fine.
I'm pretty good.
Ow.
It was dead anyway.
You can make that jump, but it's far.
Oh, how'd you guys get over there?
From where I'm standing or from there?
From where you're standing, I think?
I think that's what I did.
I got you.
Thank you.
Holy shit!
Did she just fall?
She might have just fallen like a thousand feet.
I don't think... I think she jumped kinda early.
She jumped at all!
She just walked off!
Minutes, sprint before you jump.
Oh, I made it!
See?
Nailed it.
I'm a little worried.
You made it!
Totally fine.
Yes!
Do you think she's okay?
Wait, does anybody still have the trumpet?
No, she's not okay.
She's like a sad dude.
She's...
The crime of what?
You fucking up your jump?
That's the sentence.
I don't...
I'm here to haunt you.
I don't know if this is the better way to go, or if we could go that way.
Both are viable.
I trust you!
Oh, don't do that.
That's a terrible idea.
Wait, how do we... Oh, it's a pre-haunt.
It's a pre-haunt.
Pre-haunt?
You could ask Mint how to start hunting for you.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Yeah, you have an expert right here.
I can't tell if that's getting hit by the rain or not.
It's not.
Can you shut up, Doki?
Your face is so ugly.
Wait, this is so green, though.
Mint could put her... Yeah, Mint could put her piton or something on it.
I have a piton!
I stole that from your bag, Doki!
No, let me wait for the rain, and I'll see if I can do it.
Hold on.
I got lots of extra stamina, so...
I stole it, and it actually worked.
It worked out, because I have it.
And I didn't die.
You saved it.
Oh, I see the top!
There she goes.
I see the top!
You're, like, almost there.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, there's some... there's some things here.
There's some bees!
There's bees!
Don't touch the bees!
Touch the bees!
They're strange melons!
Stuffy, touch the bees!
Eat that melon!
Eat that!
He wants to try the melon!
I'll tie it!
I'll take it!
Here you go!
Oh, oh, it's poisonous!
Oh, that looks so poisonous, dude!
Oh, no!
It just looked like a cantaloupe!
Big, the dodge!
Sound good, the sound good, okay?
Ooh!
Rope cannon!
And the water!
Do you want any?
No, I'm okay.
Actually, that fed me, like, I'm so full.
Just a little poison.
That was actually the best thing I could have had.
Yeah!
Just a little.
Just walk it up.
Yeah, I am.
The poison will eventually stop, you know?
It's like when you eat pineapple and it makes your mouth a little spiky, but it's still worth it.
I think that's called an allergy.
No!
It's eating you!
No, pineapple's technically acidic for...
Yeah, it's a eating meal.
Yeah, it is.
It is.
You're not supposed to eat pineapple.
I'm coming!
But, for some reason, people just like that.
Little freaks they are.
I'm actually, I think, allergic to kiwi, because when I eat kiwi, my mouth goes funny.
That sounds fine.
I don't think I have a spirit inside.
I'm pretty sure, like, it's supposed to do that, right?
Oh, is it?
I don't think so.
Uh, there's some more shrooms, but I don't know if those are safe.
I think.
Let me make sure.
Oh my god.
No, I don't trust your mushroom opinion.
Eat two!
Eat, eat it!
Eat two to see if it...
I did!
I ate two!
Did you just feed me one?
Oh god.
Oh no.
I'm doing good.
I ate two and I'm fine.
This one was good.
I told you.
The boogal or whatever.
The boogal?
You know this game was made in two weeks?
Was made in two weeks.
That's crazy.
This game was made in two weeks?
Yeah, it was made in two weeks.
It was supposed to be like a...
I wonder if I can jump up there or if I should go over there.
I don't know.
I think we should have followed...
I think we...
Oh, I was gonna say I think we should follow Snuffy, but never mind.
I think that one.
Oh shoot.
Oh, I made it.
Not when it's raining.
I don't think you're gonna get that way.
I don't think so.
Oh, never mind.
Wait.
Oh, please.
No!
You good?
You're okay.
Um, there is something up top.
I don't know if you can climb up there.
How do you make it?
Let me see.
I made it.
Yeah, I just have a little concussion.
Don't worry about me.
No, you definitely can't make it.
You definitely can't make it.
It's really, really far.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't like this game because I have to watch you guys fall to your death like a million times.
What do we do?
Alright, let me try this one then.
Hold on.
I think this is our best action.
I think so too.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
You have the rope.
Yeah, you have the rope to.
Where'd the rope go?
Okay.
Yeah, it's um...
Oh, we didn't need...
Okay.
But it's there now.
Hold on.
Well...
They need it.
I need it.
Maybe.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I reach that?
I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
The babies need it.
I put it down.
It should be there now.
I can't.
Okay, okay.
Oh no.
I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
Line!
Oh, grab the rope!
Grab the rope!
The babies fall.
Can I get the rope?
Okay, there you go.
Shut up.
Just because you fell and died, doesn't mean the rest of us have to.
Someone did not catch me!
They were like, you make it!
And they didn't die!
You didn't drown!
You just walked off!
They didn't, they didn't die!
And I was lied to, I ran to everything.
This ghost is noisy.
How do we turn it off?
How can, how could I fucking catch you if you plummet halfway through the chasm?
I should have been caught!
I don't know if we can get around here.
This is, this is really sketch.
Yeah, this looks bad.
There's a ledge on the, uh, there is a ledge on the bar.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
See, look at that.
I'm such a fucking helpful ghost.
She's back seating us.
Chat!
Aw, yeah!
Waiter!
We found the crevice.
Ooh, look!
An opening!
Cave diving!
We're cave diving!
Oh my god!
This is it!
This is the cave diving park!
There's nowhere else.
That looks really dangerous.
Oh my god, the fog!
The fog!
Ah!
What's bad about the fog?
I don't know.
Oh.
There's like, the left side.
There's something on the left.
Where?
Maybe we can take this right behind her.
No, no, no.
Behind you, like.
Behind you, there's...
It's green.
I don't know about that, Doki.
No, the behind you, like, a cross.
Yeah?
Okay, yeah, but, but, like, I don't think we can get any further from there.
This is like, closed.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Okay, hold on.
Yeah, I think we found the edge of the map.
We're too far over.
Oh my god, the fog is so high.
Yeah.
So those are these, like, puppets?
There's just nowhere to go.
Yeah.
I think we, we, we kind of listed too far to one side, I guess, maybe?
I think so.
Wait, look, there's a ledge on the top.
If only you had another rope.
If only.
Oh.
Oh man, my backpack had so many ropes.
It didn't have any ropes.
Stop lying.
There's something in here.
It had so many ropes.
It had none.
I looked in your backpack many times.
No, no, no.
I had at least one.
I'm going to try it with a normal mental.
Wait, men have, wait, no.
Why not use the, the yellow thing?
Can I use this?
I got a pecan.
I have a pecan.
No, I, no, the pecan.
The pecan.
I just need to find the right place to do it though.
Whatever that is.
It's a wall.
It, it, it goes in the wall and you hold it.
It looks, it looks like it's like sheer though.
Hmm.
Oh god, the fog.
The fog!
I'm afraid of you.
It's not.
Maybe, just jump in the fog.
You see?
It's, it's where all your friends are.
Oh wow, I see it.
It really is kind of foggy.
Yeah.
Whoa, it's like getting all, whoa.
Say hi.
All your friends are over there.
Come on, men, come on.
Come on.
The fog's over there too.
Oh, oh.
You're not gonna make it.
I will.
Grab.
You're not gonna make it.
So you're right.
Oh!
Hello.
I don't have enough stamina.
You look great, men.
Wait.
Min, do you have your piton still?
Yeah.
You're, you can, here.
Come on, grab this one.
Like, come up here.
And then put your piton whenever you can have enough stamina.
No, no, no, no.
You're gonna die.
No, but, oh.
No, but,
oh.
You're gonna die without me.
Wait, I keep grabbing, but it's not grabbing.
Do the last poop before you go.
Play your death play.
Wait, I'm grabbing it?
Oh, it didn't work.
Okay.
Goaloooop.
Wait,
did Stuffy die?
He died.
Oh, there I am.
Goaloo, goaloo, goaloo, goaloo.
I can't believe I slipped a bell on a banana.
Hold on, I'm gonna eat a little.
I'm gonna drink some more tea.
I'm coughing a lot today.
I don't know why.
Okay.
Eat a ghost.
I give up!
I don't think Mint knows that she...
Oh, there you are.
There she is.
Oh, you were saying...
You were using your sunglasses, too.
How do I...
Why are you so cute in your little Mint phantom-y form?
Why?
How do you move around?
Oh, you scroll wheel.
It's just that.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm so close to you.
Hey!
Hi, lady.
Oh, god.
That's not distracting.
Listen to me.
We are the ghost of Christmas past, present, and future.
Wait, you're so close.
You're so close.
Right?
Maybe?
Sniffer.
I don't know.
You're on a ledge, and it's more open now.
How do I smell?
I'm bad.
You've been on this island for days.
You do?
Yeah, it's at the very top.
Oh, my god.
No.
Okay, you look up.
I am looking up.
There's like a luggage on those vines.
That's evil.
I am not touching that shit.
Suffer.
The luggage is so evil.
Why did it do that?
Oh, my gosh.
You have such good health and everything, Lima.
That's why she's a tour guide.
Wait, why do I have a grungle?
Oh, no.
That's you.
Grungle?
It's a grungle.
It's that little bird plushie.
Yeah, it's the...
His name is Bing Bong.
Bing Bong.
You have a grungle.
Where did you get grungle from?
Yeah, where did you get grungle from it?
I don't...
I don't know.
The hottest new thing, the grungles.
Wait, I'm gonna move myself so chat can see too.
My favorite character, Mr. Grungle.
Oh, whoops, that's the game.
Is there a better path to take here?
Am I fucking stuck?
Um...
Maybe to the left?
Yeah.
To the left.
I don't think I can make that.
Hold on.
Oh, I don't think...
I don't know.
There we go.
The left side seems nice, though.
He's a lot nicer.
I noticed there's a lot less poison up here.
That's nice.
I'm just having trouble like...
Ugh.
I think you gotta go right, man.
I don't know.
Or unless you can walk up left side.
Like, it's like...
Just grab a sports drink and then YOLO.
Yeah, yeah.
That drink has sports drink.
Yeah.
And then...
Okay.
You picked the scarier part.
Nice.
She's gaming.
Oh, I see it!
There it is!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
She's doing it!
M-O-G!
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh, she's eating now.
A little bit eating.
Not too bad.
Not we.
She did it.
We did it!
We did like 90% of it, right?
Yeah!
What's up?
Yay!
I'm gonna go eat.
I'm yum yum time.
Wait, what's the darkness mean in my little meter?
I think that's like when you revive.
Where's the luggage that you're supposed to...
The...
Look, there's one up here.
What?
I don't think it's supposed to...
Where?
Is it supposed to spawn there?
What?
Can you even get...
You can't climb these kinds of shoes, can you?
Wait, what is that foot?
Yeah, what is that?
What?
Okay.
Randomly generated two of salt, I suppose.
I'm cooking my mushroom.
Not mushroom.
Marshmallow.
Did I just...
Did I just not get a mushroom?
Or a marshmallow?
I guess so.
Get someone out with two marshmallows?
We all keep...
I took only one.
I took one.
Wait, there's a...
I can cook it again?
Jokey.
Well done, marshmallow.
Did you just feed this to me?
Oh!
Why are you dying?
I was resurrected to live a life of nothing but suffering.
Wait, come here!
Come here!
I'll give you my marshmallow!
No, the yellow ones are good.
No!
The yellow ones are good.
Are you sure?
Oh, wait, no.
She fed me a green one.
Wait, it is your marshmallow!
Okay!
Okay, I'm gonna eat mine then.
Oh, wow!
Fed me it.
That's nice of you mid, though.
Double cook it.
Fed me entirely.
I gave her my marshmallow.
I'm such a good person.
Shut up!
Uh-huh.
Oh, my God!
Whoa, that looks intense!
I think the fish is on my soul now.
How did we go?
Oh, hi!
Is there a fairy in here, too?
Yeah, I don't know how long we're gonna make it, you guys.
Just us.
Oh, no.
No, we thought we had a good time.
Isn't that so, like, F-bounded?
Man, man!
You think we're supposed to use, like, one of those, like, ropes and, like, shoot that...
Yeah, I feel that.
Yeah, I feel like this is where we should have kept all our materials.
The last part is kind of, like, good for that.
Yeah.
Wow, we're doing so good.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
This is where Mount Everest mod would have came in handy.
Well, just promo.
Don't worry about it.
All the skeletons.
All the skellies.
Yeah, all the skellies scattered around.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow!
Get into shelter when that happens.
Whoa.
I'm so cool.
It made me hungry.
Oh, my God.
It's, like, on the edge of the biome.
I'm so cool.
Scout master, we got one.
This way is fine.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Let's just huddle together a little bit.
Come, come, come.
I'm coming.
I'm here.
I'm feel sort of right now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's always good in this biome that we'll have to stay near objects where we can hide behind to protect ourselves from freezing winds.
Freezing winds.
That's why.
He told me.
I caught you.
This way.
Bit chilly, innit?
Yes.
Innit?
Maybe.
Wait, there's pretty flowers here.
Can you pick these?
Ah!
Oh!
What are those?
I don't think those are flowers, are they?
I-I can't touch them, but they look pretty.
Oh, wow.
In this unforsaken cruel world, there is some beauty.
You guys look so cute huddling behind a tree over here!
Little babies over there, couldn't stand a little breeze.
A little breeze?
You guys never experience a little springtime breeze?
I should just start running.
Okay, what's in our treasure chest?
Wait, it's orange.
It's special.
Oh, it's a special rescue.
Special?
Oh!
I've been a good boy!
No, you ha- Oh my god!
Wait, that actually suits you?
Hold on.
You're filled with nothing but joy and whimsy.
Wait, that actually suits you.
The body should have been a good boy.
But your face is so mean-looking.
You're so- You need a good job at the dentist, so you get the lollipop.
Now, it's my lollipop!
You need one of the little spitter hats!
I can't have just a little tongue taste?
Goodness.
Oh wait, just a little- Just a little- Oh really?
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right.
Oh wow, yeah.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
Oh oh, the blizzard!
Don't worry.
Oh, here comes the blizzard!
Can I see my lollipop?
You wanna see it?
I'll let you- Yeah, that's huge.
It's like bigger than your head.
Can I lick you, just a little bit?
Nope.
Ten dollars.
Ten dollars?!
Ten Supas!
To me, or...?
To me.
Now it's twenty Supas.
Gosh, inflation is hurting us all.
Oh wait.
What's in- What was in there?
Um, a heating pack and an energy drink.
Whoa.
Those are good.
Oh, there's an apple!
We should get that apple for like- There's a couple apples, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
They're good.
They're winter berries.
There's a few down up here as well.
Oh, okay, I will go.
Okay, I will go.
Oh, there's a tree up there too.
Yeah.
Yeah, cause we can only fit like- A limited amount anyway.
Is there aren't ones okay?
I'll test it!
I'll taste test it.
Okay.
Look at you grabbing that.
Oh, they're real good.
Grab a bunch and put them in my pack.
I have a pack too.
Is there any more?
Put them in your pack.
How do you put things in your pack?
Uh, take your pack off, put it on the floor, and then like hold E and put it into one of the slots.
Oh.
It's really fiddly, so be careful on a mountain, cause you can actually throw your backpack off the thing.
Okay.
Wait, then you hold your- I got some oranges.
Wait, what?
I don't understand, but I believe you.
I got one orange.
Uh oh.
I don't think this is enough.
You guys okay?
Uh.
I'm okay, I'm okay right here.
Yeah, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
Okay, hold on.
I'm eating.
Okay.
Wait, actually, yeah.
No, actually you drop in, I'll put it- Oh, I was just saying, I could put it- There you go.
How do you put it in?
You, uh, you get your item out, and then you put it in.
Oh!
Oh wait.
Oh, I got it!
Okay.
Look at that!
Now we have two oranges.
What's happening to it?
Are you good?
Nice.
Hello!
Okay.
What do your eyes see- Oh, nice!
I found the musical sting!
Someone just left the heat pack on the door.
The musicals?
That was me, I ran out of room.
Whoa.
Oh.
I have, I have- I have room.
It's beautiful.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's so beautiful!
It's beaut- Ah!
Oh my god, it's not beautiful.
It's not beautiful.
It's not beautiful anymore.
Oh my god, it's not beautiful.
Run to the rock!
It's right here!
Hmm.
Yeah, we lost our bugle.
Sad, sad.
We're safe?
I'm okay!
Oh.
Take my hand!
Thank you!
Wow, she actually did it.
Teamwork!
Team player!
There's a hot spring on this map?
Somewhere!
Oh!
Thank you!
Lava!
Dangerous!
Oh, it looks...
It looks...
I don't know how to describe it.
Like a...
Like a big ol' worm.
I feel like that stumpy little walk suit, Stokia, she walks off like, Guys, the floor is lava!
And her dude's like...
Doot, doot, doot, doot, doot, doot, doot, doot, doot, doot.
Which way we going?
I'll follow you, Limel.
Uh...
This way.
I don't like jumping over the lava unless I have to.
The fog rises.
Oh, this way?
Uh...
I think I'm...
Oh, gosh.
I don't think I'm okay.
Oh, god.
No, I'm...
Oh, I'm not okay.
What?
I'm right next to the lava!
If you can get here...
Mint, mint, mint.
Yeah, over here.
Over here to me.
It's safe.
Okay.
Thanks.
Huddle together for warmth.
Yeah.
Snuggle in here a little bit.
Yeah, there we go, there we go.
Oh.
Hi, Dougie.
Hi.
Come huddle.
I don't know where Snuffy is.
Snuffy!
Well, she's clearly not dead.
I can hear her.
Yeah.
We hear you!
Marco!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I made it.
Marco!
Oh, is that a mushroom?
Or another shell fungus.
Yeah, no.
It's a...
A shell fungus so you can make it to...
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put it in your little backpack.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, where do we...
Wait, Lamo!
Yeah?
Where do we go?
Oh, there she is.
Lamo, we're lost!
We're lost!
I think maybe this way.
I hate this map.
I changed my mind.
This map sucks too.
Yeah, no.
I heard this map was the hardest part.
I thought I was like, what?
Surely the next one will be really easy.
Yeah, sure.
I actually like the next one.
The next one's good.
I like it.
Wait, have you ever beaten it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, you have?
Uh-huh.
How many tries to take you?
Uh, a few, because a couple of times I played and people were like PvP-ing.
We're not like us, because we clearly are working together.
Yeah, no.
We're working together real good.
Yeah, together.
Yeah.
We're good teammates.
Wait, what's happening?
Yay!
What's happening?
It's kinda weird, that spot there.
Uh-oh.
I don't know about this section.
It feels kinda sheer.
Oh.
Hi, Snuffy!
Is Mint okay?
Wait, where's Mint?
What is Mint?
Um, I fell a great deal.
Oh, God.
I just came from down there.
Finally.
Wait a minute.
Did we have three when we started?
Um, hmm.
Hmm.
Wait, Mint had the backpack fill with oranges, so we can't let her die.
We also can't let her die, because she's our friend!
Because there's capybara.
Yeah, she nearly has all our- all our materials.
Save, in-game!
Okay.
Wait, what?
I see the hot springs!
With the capybara!
Wait, you did?
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, I see them!
We can't go there.
We'll get fogged, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's sad.
Oh, my God.
No, they're kinda way out.
Goodbye, everybody.
Is it- there only one spot- oh!
Sophie is there.
I don't care.
I want her to.
Wait, where are you guys going?
Where do we go?
I'm watching Snuffy.
Oh, there's a spot over to the right that might work.
Okay.
Do me know then.
They just got caught by the- and the- The internals okay, but you have to go over freezing rocks, which kinda sucks.
No, she won't.
I believe, I believe.
I see her.
There she is!
She made it!
This place might be no good.
No, this place sucks.
I think we should go reconvene at the capybara and decide a different route.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I'm- I'm trying not to climb.
How do I- oh, here we go.
I'm leaving my backpack for you guys, okay?
Okay.
Whoa!
Be careful!
How'd you- how'd you- There's a big- No!
I'm okay!
Are you okay?
Yeah.
There's a big what?
Nothing!
I'm doing it!
Capybara!
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
Capybara!
Will they heal my injuries, or?
I think so.
Uh-oh.
Quickly!
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
It is?
Yeah.
Wait, I can't get up?
I actually- I don't think I can get up at all.
I have no energy.
Wait, I'm right here!
I'm so close to the capybara!
Please!
I'm on the side!
Wait, I can't- I can't do stuffy!
I can't- wait!
Oh, I'm here!
Okay, I made- I walked up.
I walked up.
I was- I was just going around in circles, being like, I don't see you on the ledge anywhere, right?
Oh.
Yes, uh, give him a good pet, too.
No, no, no.
I took all their oranges and fed them to you, but they do have wound use.
Watch this.
Wait, you look chill as hell.
Wait, me too.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Why?
Wait.
Why am I- Oh, I'm- Oh, no, it's okay.
Just stay in the water, because it combats it.
Okay, nice.
It's chill.
We're chill.
Take my hand, Capybara.
Take my hand.
I'm still really injured.
Well, it wasn't a healing spring.
But maybe we can find something on the way up.
Surely we'll make it- They're only up there.
Yeah, they-
I wonder if I'm distracting her.
Honestly, Snuffy, I don't think I can make it.
That's not true.
Okay, okay.
I have- I got nothing.
No, no, no, don't waste it on me!
No, why would you do that?
It's never a waste if it helps you.
It is a waste.
That's a useful item.
No, you're just a- You're a fellow scout.
I wouldn't have a troop if it wasn't for my fellow scout.
Oh, thanks.
Thanks, fellow scout.
No problem.
Thankfully, this is a pretty easy- Maybe the Capybara's were the right choice.
Yeah, the Capybara's were the right choice!
Oh, hey, kids!
Hi!
Hello, parents?
Oh, you guys left my backpack!
I don't think we do.
They didn't even take it.
I'll put it on.
Wait, I kind of need an apple from there.
Yeah, yeah, here.
Wait, how do I grab it?
I'll wear it since it makes you heavy.
Oh, I grabbed it?
Okay.
Yummy!
Okay, I feel better.
A little bit?
A lot of bit.
We need to find, like, first aid for you.
We're right- we're together, so I feel better.
I feel so bad.
Yeah, I won't leave you behind!
I've got a pusher.
Oh!
Oh, we- Okay.
We're back here!
I remember this vibe.
Don't-don't-don't fall into that hole!
Yeah, I've fallen in there before.
Wait up here, up here!
There's, like, multiple pathways you can take, and I think we could have ended up on one.
That's not great.
Okay, I think...
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Oh!
Can you try here?
Oh no, I fell!
Oh no!
Oh!
Um...
Ow!
Are you good?
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
I don't know, I'm stuck!
Oh no!
Oh, this is...
I kept doing this before too, where I kept going in a little loop.
Why do I do that to myself?
Oh!
No!
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
I'm fine!
Oh, okay.
What a beautiful night.
The moon is nice and crescent.
And the lava is flowing and keeping me warm.
Oh, ouch.
Never mind.
I'm not warm at all.
Mine died?
What?
Mine died!
Oh no, no, no.
Uh-oh.
Oh no!
Okay, Scoutmaster down!
Scoutmaster down!
We'll never make it.
Doki, how did you kill Lime?
We'll be honest.
How did you do it?
What was the weapon?
Her own face.
I ate my lollipop before I died.
You think you're Lollipop?
Ouch!
Uh, Snuffy?
I think this is the end of the road for me.
Oh no!
Don't quit!
Don't you leave!
I think I'm gonna go back to them Capybara and I'm just gonna resign to my thing.
I swear to fuck you, go back to those goddamn Capybaras.
I slipped on a- on a weird jump and I'm dead.
And Doki died like right next to me.
Oh, she's dead too!
Doki died?
Yeah, we're both dead.
I guess you guys should've gone to the Capybara.
Yeah, everybody who went to the Capybara are alive.
I mean, if you go- if you go like around where Snuffy's going, you'll find our bodies and all our stuff so you can get some stuff.
Yay, stuff!
No, I'm not giving you that satisfaction.
Oh, that's fucked up.
That one's fucked up.
That one is me.
I guess my back- Oh my god!
Unless it fell off my body.
Oh, there's Grangle!
There's Grangle!
Is that Dingbong?
Yeah.
There he is!
I mean, it looks like you might be able to climb up there as well.
You know, if you wanted to give it a go.
Where did you die?
No, look at- look at Ms. Hellfire.
Look- Yeah, there's no way I'm gonna make it.
I told you!
I need to go- Nuffy's gonna gamer her way up.
You can!
No, no, don't give it to me!
Don't feed it to- Don't waste it on me!
You're like allergic!
No police anything!
Save it for yourself!
I have my EpiPen!
I have like- I have like almost more than half.
I'm good.
No, if you see what we saw, Ms. Hellfire, you do not want her to have it.
I know!
I don't know.
Should we go here?
I'm gonna follow you, Scout Master.
Okay, you're the new Scout Master.
Oh no!
Oops, ouch!
I'm fine.
You're not the Scout Master.
Oh, what is this?
I think I see a mushroom!
Oh, look at that!
Look at that's a glowing thing!
It's a- It's one of those things!
It's a baton!
I found an old baton.
You can't see anything.
I think I just look blind.
Uh-oh.
Hello?
Are you over here?
Don't go, Freddy!
Stop!
I can't!
Wait, I can see your name!
You look like God!
Huh?
I can see nothing but bright lights and you're just radiating behind it.
You look like a- you look like a holy intervention.
Oh, I can't make it.
I need you to climb that, yeah.
Wait, we could have just followed the old thing.
Oh, there's a suitcase up there!
It's gonna be stuffed!
Yeah, there's a suitcase!
Try and climb on the right side.
The right side's less steep.
It didn't look like that at all for me.
Wait, I'm gonna climb this tree.
Is this a better idea?
Uh-oh.
Hey, what are you talking about?
Hey, you went up the right hand side!
Yeah, I listened to Laimu.
The-the scout master.
The scout master, the butterfinger to jump.
Wait, there's only a- And now I'm scout dancer.
There's only a rope in here though.
That's unfortunate.
I'm in the deep of the scout master!
Hello!
I like all the ice rocks hanging out next to the actual lava.
That seems-that seems okay.
I think this was actually the more correct path.
Yeah, there's like a-there's a hole- No, I-I-I-I, you can do either.
I fucking hate internally.
So, internally like, takes out the storm, but then every time you touch those blue rocks, you accumulate freezing points.
So if you have to, like, run across them or something, enter.
Here, I can think I can do it.
You can pull the heat pack, though, and do it.
You can probably make it.
Well, the problem is, is there anything above this, though?
I don't think so.
No, there's not really.
Go this far left, you see what I see?
There's rocks there.
What is this?
Are these good for your soul or bad?
The glowy blue one?
Oh, that is good for your soul.
Hide it.
Not that close.
I'm trying.
Is it warm?
Yeah, too hot.
Too hot.
What does the grungle do?
Where'd he go?
Oh, he didn't do anything.
Haha, grungle.
He's just like a little companion.
I'll put him in your backpack.
This is definitely the right way.
Definitely.
I told you guys.
Why are you gonna climb that?
Oh, look it.
This is all I can do.
Ooh, delicious.
What is it?
For you.
No, she's not hungry.
No, I'm not hungry.
I'm not hungry.
It's great.
It was just a little treat.
Why do you keep doing this?
Oh my gosh.
I think we're heading back to the capybara.
It's gonna be that kind of grandma where you visit and then like you're trying to leave and she's like, oh, take these with you.
Oh, and these as well.
And then she like finds like, I don't know, like eight different cakes and she's like, you should take some of these as well.
And then a snack for the road and you can use this for your dinner.
I can see the capybara from here.
Oh, shoot.
Uh oh.
I'm safe.
I think.
Oh, she's safe now.
Come to me.
It's good here.
Be careful though.
If I fall, I'll die.
It's a bizarre travasse between us.
No, you won't.
You'll be fine.
Ah, we'll see about that.
Why is the grungle so heavy, actually?
I'm gonna get rid of him.
No, I carried him the entire way.
Don't you fucking dare.
You whore.
I don't even have anything in my inventory.
I lost like 10 pounds in my inventory.
Okay, so that was the weight of your heart shriveling into a prune.
Do you see my health?
There is no...
You could have given it to Snuffy.
Sacrifices are supposed to be made.
Oh, the snowstorm's gone.
Okay, I'm gonna jump for it.
Throw the ring in the volcano.
It's like, it's like the ring from Lord of the Rings.
Yeah, but throwing it in the volcano.
You guys were...
Little do you know you've cursed the entire run because you let him die.
Oh, yeah, that's what cursed the run.
You really think you see we're gonna make it to the top.
Do you really think?
You guys were like, my precious grungle.
And you just couldn't see...
It's grungle!
You couldn't see...
The...
The truth.
I showed it to you.
I'm following Snum.
Snum vision.
Thank you.
It's a tall vision.
I mean, snums naturally are pretty good in the snow, so...
Yeah.
Oh, dang.
Oh!
No, nevermind.
Oh, there's the blizzard.
Hide!
Come here!
It's actually, you're making good progress.
You found a better part of the mountain to climb.
I believe in you.
I don't have any...
I have a rope.
Actually, hold on.
Let me put this into your back.
It's...
It's a new map every day.
Doki.
But it's the same map each time.
So if we tried it again, it would be the same mountain.
Yeah, so we'll know.
We'll know how that will be this way.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm trying.
Let me try and climb this tree.
Okay.
And then...
And then either...
I think...
Oh.
Okay.
You just tell your friends to just die.
No, I said either.
Just jump up.
No, I'm talking about Doki.
I said...
You should just die.
I expected that.
It's such an easier decision to make.
Don't you guys like the easy choice?
Yeah, I love...
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
Right here, right here, right here.
Maybe?
Uh, nope.
Nope.
Never mind.
No, I'm dying.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
I'm trying.
Oh.
Good thing I gave her the rope, right?
I give up.
Press an E.
Oh.
Look at me.
Oh, no.
No.
Stop it.
Your body was never found.
New hat.
Hat.
Oh, give me a witch.
Ooh.
Explorer.
Four.
How many...
Oh, I guess there must be, what?
Two more?
Three?
Maybe?
Grungled.
Oh.
We got cursed.
You threw the grungle and he like...
I told you.
You threw bing bong and he lives.
Why are your eyes...
Why do you look like that?
You can't just say that about your friends.
Are you okay?
Were your eyes always like that?
Maybe they were always like that.
They're so far into her head.
I know.
It looks like she's got like a migraine.
She is actually Blair Witching.
What's wrong?
Oh.
Dude.
Not good.
What's that good?
You good?
Oh.
Oh no.
It's been turning off all day.
Come in.
To us.
You may have a power problem.
Oh my god.
I tried it on YouTube.
Are you good?
I don't know.
Your whole computer might be like...
Breaking.
I know.
You're cutting it out.
Doki.
She's like fucking possessed.
That's actually terrifying.
She's alive.
She's literally like...
Put her back in the elevator.
Be gone.
Put your back in there.
She won't go.
She's heavy.
She's resisting.
Oh god.
She's moving.
What is she doing?
Breaking it down.
No, no, no, no.
I don't like that.
Oh, Doki's streaming offline.
Oh, it did?
It's gone, gone.
Yeah.
Is it gonna...
Hold on, hold on.
Let me try something.
Doki!
Come back to us!
Grab my hand, Doki!
Doki!
Grab my hand!
Laimu, are you okay?
It's the capybara curse!
They didn't capybara!
They didn't grace a capybara, and now they've been like...
They've been shadow...
Shadow banned!
Her eyes are freaking out too!
They are?
Llama, wake up!
Snap out of it!
Oh no!
Hey, I'm back!
Did Doki's possession end?
Like, as I walked into the room, she was twitching and her eyes were rolling back into her head.
Is she good?
The stream died!
She's gone!
Oh no!
It wasn't your fault, but it might have been ours.
I think it's because she didn't pet the capybara.
I think so too.
True.
I mean...
Like, you know...
As things go, I feel like that was actually a really good run.
Like...
I'm surprised that our first run, considering that Ndoki hadn't done it either, we actually made that far.
I don't even think my first run was that good.
You got pretty far!
Yeah!
Proud of us.
On my first run, I didn't know it was timed, so I was like...
Taking such scenic routes, and I was like...
Getting so immersed, and I was like...
Yeah, and then the fog shows up, and it's like, oh no.
Get fog.
It was like, this is...
It's getting misty!
This is cool weather!
And then I'm like, freezing to death.
I guess...
I guess Doki is restarting her PC.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
That's a good one.
Thanks.
Yeah.
That's really original.
I'm gonna go...
Do some cool...
poses in the mirror.
Hopefully if she fixes her computer...
I can do one more run if she fixes her computer.
Yeah, yeah.
I guess I'll just...
Cause it's like...
It's like 1am.
Oh no!
It's fine, it's fine.
I have stupid sleeping hours anyway.
Change my hat!
But I like my hat!
I'm gonna take a nap at the airport like when you do.
Minto, if you...
If you dance and then stick your heart...
Your arm out, you can like whip a nae nae.
What?
Nene!
Whip!
Watch me!
Watch me nae nae!
Watch me whip!
Watch me nae nae nae!
Yay!
Welcome back!
Oh well I guess she can't hear me right...
...for it's back in the red side of Sun...
Oh is she in?
I suddenly said...
Oh is she on Discord?
The spirit of Doki is returning, I sent her!
Oh yay!
Dude, it was honestly...
As I walked back into the room...
She was just like looking straight up...
Her eyes rolled back and her...
I know!
Her like dupe was twitching...
It was fucking awful!
It was scary!
It was actually scary!
I don't...
I don't think...
I'm gonna invite her or something...
How do you invite people to this game?
Oh there's a...
There's a little thing over here...
It says invite...
Invite friends...
Uh Doki...
Oh yeah...
I am...
I sent one...
Okay good good...
Bing bong!
Oh wait...
Maybe that's where I got Grunkle from...
Oh wait no...
Bing bong was his actual name...
I still don't know where you got Grunkle from...
Hello!
What happened?
Oh my...
What happened to me?
It was...
You were legitimately possessed...
Oh wait...
It's like...
My main father died...
And then like...
Everything was...
I just...
I just feel like...
Like...
Everyone cut in and out...
And then...
And then like...
Everyone just kept looping...
I just...
All I heard was just...
Me laughing...
And it was the same laugh...
Over...
And over...
And over again.
It never stopped.
And then I force quit my game.
That sounds like a nightmare.
Legitimately, you got Bing Bong cursed.
That's fucked up.
She was the one that threw it in the hole.
Whip.
Watch me, Nae Nae.
Nae Nae.
Whip.
I taught her to whip and Nae Nae.
I need a... Am I the same character?
Yeah, you are.
I'm a lawnmower, guys.
I need some guy to help me again.
Everything reset itself.
What the fuck did you do?
Wait, what did you do?
I was doing the lawnmower.
You danced.
Wait, you... We have a new hat.
I have a new hat.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
You look... Oh, I like your hat.
I don't like it.
It's my hat.
Wait, why?
I have an objective for you.
I don't like your hat either.
If you bring the bugle to the capybaras and play it to them, you get a hat.
No way.
Really?
Yeah.
They like your music.
Let's go.
No!
Cute.
I didn't know that.
It's happening.
Everything paused.
Oh, my God.
What?
Is your computer dying?
Are you okay?
Oh, my God.
I'm not okay.
There's no way Peak is gonna destroy my PC.
Have you... Is your framerate capped?
Or, you know, are you overheating your computer with Peak?
No.
No, I capped it at... I'm gonna capped it at 144.
The people can only see 60.
Okay, you shut the fuck up right now.
Shut up, man.
You shut up.
Oh, my God.
Why is my PC?
You see gamers are like, shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Why?
I hate my PC.
Stop.
You just push your... No!
Whip.
Nene.
No.
All right.
Wait.
Do you need... Do you need to tap out?
Yeah, wait.
I didn't... It's... It's my sound guide lets me know if everyone's volume...
Apparently, when you rejoin a session, it resets your volume sliders.
It does, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so I didn't know if everything... I didn't know if all the volume's okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm ready, though.
I'm ready.
Go on vacation.
Wee!
Wee.
Come on vacation.
Demon's doing the splits on the elevator.
Wee.
Wee!
Oh, my God.
So are you.
Let's gooo.
They call me the Man of Steel.
I'm ready.
I'm locked in.
I'm pouring my ticket.
Wait.
She's doing a thing.
I can't.
I'm crying.
I'm alive.
We're alive.
Alright, skats.
Give me the bugle.
Oh, how did I grab... I didn't grab that.
It's always about the bugle.
Give me the bugle.
Give it to me.
Maybe that's why you called it the bungle.
That's only one letter away from bugle.
You were just thinking about your bugle this whole time.
I think you get a hat if you take him to the top, too.
Take him.
We have two missions.
Scout.
Thank you.
Who's taking Bungle?
Take Bungle.
You take him, Snuffy.
I got food.
I'll take Bungle.
I want to grab the food, too.
Wait, who has the backpack?
Me!
Oh.
Okay, now we're not gonna...
Show the way now!
We're gonna go.
We know, yeah.
Lead the way, Scoutmaster!
Lead the way!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm gonna get a coconut for the journey.
We don't need the compass, I don't think.
Oh!
Actually, if you take the compass...
No!
I got a granola bar.
I got a snack for a long time.
It's a sacred piece of Scout merchandise!
We don't need the compass where we're going.
Go!
Gosh, my...
My lung capacity is great.
Oh, there's that floating guy again!
Wait, so it's the same map now, right?
Yeah, it's the same map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the same map.
Do you remember how we got to the top?
No.
Who just said no?
Coconut!
Coconut's on the floor!
I pick one up.
Yeah!
I have a little snack.
And I threw it on the floor!
Oh!
Ah!
Wait, what happened to me?
Wait, Limeo, I'll put it in your backpack.
Oh, yeah, I mean...
They're very heavy.
Just eat them now, I think.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, they're like super heavy for what they are.
I'll carry this one for me.
I just...
You put that shit in my backpack, didn't you?
No.
Okay.
Yeah, I believe you.
I mean, the number went up to show that you did, but okay.
Let me check.
Let me check for you.
Maybe you went through like a growth spurt.
Yeah, maybe you had pu- second puberty.
You gained an extra appendage.
Did you check?
Yeah, I did.
I checked.
And did you put more in my fucking backpack, Min?
Did she check?
No, I just went to check.
What do you- why did I get in?
She's the one that pointed in!
It was awful!
And then Snuffy put one in my fucking backpack as well because I still have four!
Snuffy map saved it!
Put your coconut in your backpack!
It wasn't neat!
Wait, what the heck?
Wait, you guys need to look at this.
There's something of- this whole map is very obscure.
Why?
It is.
Oh yeah!
I like- I like the mushrooms growing on the suitcase.
Those are the roots that I- that were the- the- the roots from before.
It was left to- Somebody had some home growing in here.
Are you safe?
Are you tired?
Are you okay?
I'll eat it.
I'll chop this.
Alright.
It's safe.
Maybe if you eat one.
Is it?
Maybe just one.
Just one.
Just a little poison as a treat.
Like- I think I have a better tolerance now.
Yeah, like you- If you eat poisonous mushrooms once a day, you become immune.
I saw an- I saw an art- like I saw like a tweet.
Where someone was like, I shot myself in the leg.
Um, every day.
Oh yeah.
I can make my skin bulletproof.
And then I see that tweet.
Nothing to lose.
Hang on.
Thicments.
A scout.
Thicments!
Oh!
I got an energy drink.
It's kind of weird that they just put you on a box like this.
It's an American only.
Whoa!
Oh, I need those.
Did you just use the energy drink?
Was I not supposed to?
Yeah!
Oh, it's- it's fine.
Oh, I'm tired now.
Yeah.
Aw.
Wait, how do I get untired?
Can I take a nap?
Apparently this guy was trying to- Nah, you just wait.
Okay, I'm gonna play dead.
And then he, like, upgraded to a really strong bullet.
And then he went to the hospital.
Yeah.
Oh, take that granola bar for later.
No, he was like, I had to stop.
So I hope someone else continues my research.
More energy drinks.
You had to stop shooting himself in the leg.
Do we go this way?
Cause to the right, I think is the way we went first time and it was no good.
Right?
Yeah!
You're the ones that were supposed to remember for us.
I don't remember.
This is all a blur.
I think I was in fight or flight by the time we- I had no idea what was going on.
The first two matches were, like, super easy.
And then there was, like, a- some difficulty fight for some reason.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
I remember we crossed the bridge.
We just gotta find the bridge.
There's been a few.
I think I'm lost.
Wait.
Oh.
Don't come to me.
I don't know if anybody was in a hurry.
You were, like, throwing yourself into a pit.
Me?
Yeah.
Can we go here?
Can we climb up here?
Can we walk on this?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Just a little bit.
Okay.
You can then go, like, here, and then here, and I'll- I'll- I'll catch you.
I'll- I'll, like, bring you up.
Okay.
Bulletproof.
Wait, what is that big ol' character?
You might be able to walk up that way.
Nothing to lose.
I'm heading up.
Fire away, fire away.
I only know the My Little Pony version of that song.
I'm s- What's the Pony version of that song?
Yeah, what's the Pony version?
It's called Octavia.
I am Octavia.
Oh, thank you.
There you go.
You're welcome.
I almost- I almost didn't make it.
Imagine not making it.
Ah, but I did, so...
Oh, I see the bridge!
I see the bridge!
I'm heading to the bridge!
Oh, we're making such good time, because before, the fog was already at the bridge, right?
Yeah!
How do we get to the- oh, wait, we have to go down.
Look at us go!
We're speedrunning!
I don't think it's your monitor.
You literally had to reset your PC.
Yeah, if your whole computer turned off, I think it might be like your graphics card or driver or something.
Not again?
Not again!
Why do I always get these PC problems?
Not again?
What are you doing to your poor PC?
I don't know!
I don't even know.
I think we went- yeah.
What about going after this?
Oh, up!
Go up!
Turn around!
Yeah.
Is it- this way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I don't know where you're going, I wasn't looking.
Okay.
It's Marvel Rivals is what my chat said.
Marvel Rivals?
Have you tried uninstalling Marvel Rivals?
Yeah, it's like maybe it's Marvel Rivals mining all that crypto on your computer.
Yeah, it's mining crypto.
Oh wait, I need a rush.
Oh yeah, I launched Marvel Rivals for like the first time since the tournament just to buy Loki in a swimsuit.
Oh yeah, he's like... he has a bug too.
His whole thing is out, it's amazing.
It's actually an actual bug.
Yeah, I bought that so quick.
Yeah, they're finally giving people what they want.
Yeah, yeah, he has a bulge.
Help!
That's so far!
Thank you.
Crane quench!
Is it left side?
I don't remember you.
I don't remember which way we went.
Me too.
I'm gonna Google it.
Somebody check the GPS.
If I... I got my...
Wait, are you Googling Loki's bulge?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Maybe do Marvel Rivals...
Loki Summer Skin.
Loki bulge will get me...
Yeah, maybe don't Google Loki bulge.
Don't just Google Loki's bulge.
That's not gonna go well.
Don't just do that.
That might not be the best.
Oh, I did.
But it's not...
Hold on, wait.
Loki...
That's not fair.
He was naked, apparently, in the show.
So this was a set up.
Marvel Rivals...
Summer Skin.
Whoa!
Ah!
I regret looking it up!
Minch, are you okay?
Are you screaming because you're falling or screaming because you look at Loki's bulge?
Because I looked at it!
And it looked at me back!
Wait, where are you guys?
Oh.
Uh, we went up.
We just kept going up while you were moving in.
Okay!
Uh, do you think I can make it?
Or...
This one here, this one here first.
Okay.
Thanks!
I don't see this.
Can you guys linger?
Did you see you're getting a tapeworm?
Because I can't see it, I'm gonna get a tapeworm.
Oh!
Oh, okay, hold on.
Let me...
Let me send you Loki's bulge.
Give me a minute.
I only got like a Nexus mod link to Loki's bulge.
No, I had to search the summer skin.
But don't.
Be prepared.
I put it in the group chat for you, Snuffy.
It's uploading.
It will look back at you.
Oh my!
That's like real, real?
Uh oh.
Yeah, it's real.
Uh, Doki!
Doki!
Oh no!
Mint, are you okay?
I got you, I got you this time.
Yeah!
Snuffy saved me!
I just...
No!
Doki's not a team player.
You can stop here if you want first.
This one works too.
I almost was just too distracted watching Loki bulge.
Stop where?
Here?
Oh.
I got you, I got you.
Add the lunge.
Thank you.
This way, Snuffy.
Okay, I'm coming up through this.
Okay, you're going a different way?
I'm leaving then.
Bye!
Oh.
I'm right behind you.
Okay.
Oh.
Look at you.
Why is she talking to herself over there?
I don't know.
I'm at chat right now.
Why aren't you...
I just put push to talk on.
I swear the fuck, Doki climbs one mountain, she thinks she's a pro.
I know.
She's leaving us behind.
We needed her hand.
Wait, do you have any more coconuts?
Dang, she's all the way over there.
I do not have coconut.
This was not the right way.
Don't worry, man.
What's in your bag, though?
It is this way.
What's in your bag?
I have your specialty.
Oh.
Would you like some thick mint?
Wait, maybe it's...
Wait, no, no, wait.
I just...
Can I have like a little snack?
Wait, who is there?
Yeah, of course.
It's like multi-use.
Yeah, yeah.
This way, this way.
Thank you.
Which way?
Of course.
This way, this way.
I realized I have a granola bar, too.
Oh, this way.
This way, okay.
Alright.
This way.
Follow the Scoutmaster.
Scoutmaster knows the way.
She know the way.
Don't help Doki up.
Thank you.
Wait, isn't it just one at a time?
Ideally.
Okay.
You can like roll the dice on it if you want.
I think I'm ready to start betraying people now.
What?
They climb one mountain and it's all over.
Everybody's turning evil.
Yeah, I climb one mountain and I know what I'm doing.
Like lost or something.
The show.
The show lost?
I've never seen it, so I'm making this claim that I'm alive.
No, no, no, no.
Get away from me.
What?
Those are safe.
I ate them myself.
You can't climb while you have a trumpet.
No, those are safe.
Red is good.
Green is bad.
Yellow is good.
Okay, that's good.
Wait, for what?
For eating.
The first berries.
Oh.
Blue bananas are good too.
I saw that I was trying to force me.
I'm climbing something now.
No, I was selfishly eating it myself.
Oh, hold on.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
I see the campfire!
Dang, we really made it through this one fast.
Because we're pros.
We're freaking pros.
We're freaking awesome.
I'm not hours too good at this.
You're like...
You were like...
Bashing yourself on the rock like a seal.
And you're like, We're freaking chaos.
I'm just like...
Okay.
Yeah.
Oops.
What do we get?
Oh, there's a train launcher.
You have to pick this antidote because she puts everything in her mouth.
Oh, yeah.
Get the antidote.
Oh, I got the back.
Actually...
The antidote?
I want the fairy.
What is the straw on the foot?
Oh, we have a moron.
What is this?
Uhhh...
Oh?
Why'd it get all scary all of a sudden?
I got the anti-rope spool!
Yay.
Wait, I can pick some stuff up.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
How much stuff do we got in the...
In the...
In the backy packy?
My backpack's full now.
What if I cook it too much?
It makes it well done.
What if you do it one more time?
Is it burnt?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't think you do it three times, you do it two.
Yeah, I think we'd actually... I want that back.
Oh, yeah.
People keep just putting stuff in my thing!
Okay.
Oh!
To the top!
To the friendship!
I'm coming!
Isn't there a song from High School Musical?
Like, to the top, bop, bop, bop, to the top, bop, bop, to the top.
Take it higher.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, till we drop.
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
I'm gonna push Doki off the cliff.
Pop, pop, pop.
I feel like I'm in, like, a car ride.
Blop, blop, blop.
We're gonna keep pushing higher.
Blop, blop, blop, blop, blop, blop.
I'm following Snuffy.
Blop, blop, blop, blop.
Magic bean!
Magic bean.
Take ya higher.
Bop, blop, blop.
So, we need to have, like, leftists, right?
We're Snuffy sisters!
Because we ended up, like, too far right?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I can take care of this man.
Yeah, we ended up too far right, so we wanna circle around to the left.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I dropped down.
I'm gonna drop this.
Oh, there's a suitcase!
Look, look, look!
Yeah, we saw that before.
I'm grabbing a suitcase.
Yeah, maybe we go more to the left since the right side was, like, suffering last time.
Yeah, yeah.
What is this?
Oh, it's the shelf fungus.
I broke my leg and now I can use a med kit.
Use the energy drink.
Okay.
Yeah.
Use it.
I'm gonna eat my marshmallow first and then I will put it in here.
Yeah, eat it.
No, drink it.
I did.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, it didn't do the same thing?
And then we go up.
Yeah.
I'm gonna do the thing.
Wait.
Look at us go.
Where's Snuffy?
I'm gonna climb it.
Snuffy!
Lava said we shouldn't climb when it's raining, but dude, she's a liar.
That's our scout master!
That's our scout...
Scalpin used the vine!
Yeah!
That's cool.
I like that.
Look at you just standing there with no...
Do you not know...
Do you not know how to use the right button anymore?
Help!
You bitch.
Oh my god, I'm okay.
I...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
That was scary.
I didn't mean to call you a bitch then.
I thought you were just refusing to help me up.
Are you good?
I thought so too.
I'm okay.
The grunkle...
Guys, my PC...
The grunkle curse is going strong.
Oh my...
I think...
Honestly, I think your computer might be on the way out.
Yeah!
There's something going on.
Oh my god.
Do you have like an Intel CPU?
Are you melting it away in real time?
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
PTSD please!
I think I might have to take you to the doctors later.
Yeah, maybe a little bit.
I don't know...
I don't know what's going...
Okay, I have a...
I still think...
I think we need to lean left.
I think so too, yeah.
I think we're too far right again.
Hold on.
I think so.
Oop.
This is a trap.
Slip, slip, slip, slip, slip.
Oh!
I got boiling.
Look, are you hungry?
Whoa!
A whole bento!
That looks tasty.
It's actually airline food, but...
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Wait, what if I go in the water?
Oh wait, the fog is here already.
That's beans.
Okay, we're going.
Oh, I touched the thing.
Yeah, I certainly touched it a little bit.
Oh, oh, oh, it just took a minute.
You have to water it.
Ew, it's a grower.
Dude, it's so big.
Holy shit.
Whoa!
I think, I think this might have been a slight waste of it.
Wait, is this gonna...
Why did you waste it?
I...
Why did you waste this, Slip?
I should have been more thoughtful about my uses.
Yeah.
I wanna get to the tip.
I hope you learned your lesson.
Careful!
If you go to the tip, you might slow!
I didn't even do anything!
Woo!
What's your footing?
Oh, there's apples.
Is anybody hungry?
A little bit.
But I have tronics.
I felt like I was in the line.
We need to, we need to hang left.
We're on the edge of the map again somehow.
Yeah!
We just wanna get it.
Apparently.
Uh oh.
I'll wait.
Look at the tip.
Uh...
Lion King.
I don't know yet.
I have a mission.
Yeah, I got to take this to the...
I'm waiting.
It's taking a long time.
Come on, go away.
Beep!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, you know what?
I'm not waiting.
I don't know.
Oh, thank you.
Damn, why are you waiting for me?
Yeah!
Hmm.
Which way did they go?
Oh, up here.
Yeah, I think they went this way.
That's the right way.
Scout Master!
Ouch!
Oh, thanks.
It's very useful.
How's it going?
You're welcome, Scout Master.
I don't detect a whole lot of sincerity in your voice.
You're welcome.
Does this ever disappear?
I don't know.
Oh, no.
We're not going this way?
I don't know.
I don't know which way I should go.
We have several...
Doki has several ropes.
I'm just gonna say that.
Out loud.
Um...
Yeah, I do.
Don't shame her.
I'm not shaming.
I'm just saying that.
Yeah, you tattle killer.
I'm just saying that if we need to use things to get further, that someone is hoarding the supplies.
I am not hoarding anyone else can open my backpack.
It's not just a neat thing.
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna push her off.
I'm gonna murder you.
I'm gonna kill you.
We're in the other map again.
I don't know if we can go anywhere else.
Let's just go to the left side, right side.
Left side, right side.
But we kind of stranded ourselves by going down.
Why are you looking at me like that?
What the hell?
If we can get over here, that is such an easy way up.
How did you get so tall?
What happened?
Did you see what happened?
She like ricocheted.
I think Doki just killed her.
Oh wait, Limo, are you okay?
You're alive!
She's alive, she's alive, she's alive!
Oh my god, how does she live?
Yeah, that's something a killer would ask.
Doki, how did she live because you pushed her off and you were intending...
With intent to kill!
How does she have no stamina for that?
Send the rope!
Wait, we can use the rope down here and then go to where the ammo is.
Or you could be gamers and catch the vine.
What could possibly go wrong?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, let's do it.
No, use the rope if you're scared, use the rope if you're scared.
Nope.
Alive!
Oh, no, I'm not.
Um...
It did start raining, did she just like, slip and die?
I don't know.
Can we check on her?
Can we stay through?
Oh, maybe she didn't know she had to press E.
Oh, it was E?
I thought it was E.
I think so.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Before I do this, Snuffy, go back up.
Snuffy, before we do this.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna put the backpack down and then...
I need to get out.
Oh, no!
I can't see Min's body.
Hi, Min!
Hi!
Hello!
I turned my camera just in time to see you going by so fucking fast!
I didn't know it was, uh...
Uh, left...
Uh, E to...
To grab, I thought it was...
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I should've said something.
I didn't think about it.
You gotta press E.
Yeah.
Aw, rip the bugle.
That was funny, though.
What happened to me?
Are you okay?
You're...
You're looking...
You look like you...
Kevin Butters will be so disappointed.
I know, it's okay.
Do something!
What are you doing?
I'm...
Oh my god, now I can.
Okay.
I'm gonna jump down.
It's left click.
It's left click to grab it.
I know, Andy!
Fuck it!
Please!
I'm okay.
How is she...
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Grab the bugle.
Grab it from my body.
Me, me!
I'm not!
I'm gonna grab your stupid bugle!
Please!
I'm alive.
I know if I can back up.
You're going to get fogged first.
Don't say that!
You're going to get fogged.
Stop!
Get fogged, Doki bird!
I wasn't!
Get fogged.
Get stick bugged.
That's just a fart.
What the hell?
This is all your fault.
This is your fault!
I thought you were alive!
Did you tell her the wrong button, Min?
No!
Are you sure?
She did that all on her own.
This is all your fault, Min!
You messed with my groove!
Excuse me, Min, you've thrown off Doki Bird's groove.
I'm not sorry!
I'm crying.
Oh, okay.
My POV was so good!
You did this.
From mine, I just saw Doki fucking bounce.
It was so good.
You cursed me.
Just kidding.
Snuffy has the rest of the backpack.
Okay, good.
Is Snuffy alive?
Hi, Snuffy.
Oh, I was like, I don't know where everybody went.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know how she...
Wait, you died!
Wait, did you live?
How did you die?
What happened?
Someone, someone...
Oh, oh, I was not doing anything.
Someone cursed me to all eternity.
Oh, that's kind of nice, though.
That's so romantic.
You guys can haunt me together.
I'm dead!
What do you mean?
To be fair, as soon as I saw you hit the ground, I kinda marked you as deceased.
It was, like, a pretty bad, like, brain trauma.
It was a pretty bad trauma.
Yeah, it was really bad.
You had internal bleeding.
There was, like, adrenaline shock from the hit.
So, like, I didn't die right away.
Like, Trezna was taking me over to the edge.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm gonna check on that.
Okay, I'm waiting.
No, no, I have to...
No, no, if you go too far, the Scout Master spawns, I'd knock you off the mountain.
It's too much to him for him to graduate.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Did he fucking spawns and kiss you?
Yeah, he chases you down and, like, takes you off the mountain.
He's like, wow, you're not working as a team?
Go fuck yourself.
Wow, okay, so all we need is Snuffy to die, then.
What?!
Or, you know, get to me, one or the other.
Cause that one's just as likely to help.
Did you hear that?
Snuffy was like, what?!
Somebody!
I don't hear her now.
Please!
Insult after insult, I was somebody!
There's only four minutes!
It's okay, it's okay, you'll be fine.
Did you hear something?
Somebody just said something to me.
I know, what was that?
They have the voice of a ghost, so I don't know.
You said what, Mint?
Aw, it must have been Mint.
What did she say?
Are you able to get up, Snuffy?
Um...
She doesn't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
I can like...
Can you get to here?
Oh, shoot!
You're literally right there, next to her!
I got you, I got you.
This way!
Hey!
Big girl!
What's up?
Wait, what is this?
Like, wind?
Do you see wind or something?
Yeah, I don't know what that's about.
I think it's a broken waterfall.
Yeah.
It's like a sideways water.
At least it's no kick thing.
Yeah.
This, honestly, this map generation seems kind of funky.
Oh yeah, here it is.
What's your fault?
I do think getting robbed out of our, like, big luggage at the top is kind of cool for the army.
So do we want to go this way?
Or around this way?
This way seems kind of clean and nice.
Yeah.
That's my main bar, if he's sickering from black screen to me, that's not good, right?
That's...
No, that's usually...
It's evolving!
Congratulations!
Your graphics card.
It's trying to talk to you.
I don't think that's it.
Hold on, let me...
Let's check this way around.
This whole place stopped...
I might need to take a PC to the doctor's tomorrow.
A wellness check.
I haven't installed my new CPU yet, because I didn't have time to go to the...
The...
The PC people.
Another cookie.
Okay.
Where did she go?
She went to the other side.
Please come back...
Go back down.
Going down?
Yeah.
She went...
The left side.
Where you came from.
She went the other way.
Oh.
I'm coming.
Which way did you go?
You're on the vine.
I don't know in regards to you.
Oh, there you are.
Snuffy's on a mission.
I don't remember how we get up top.
I don't remember the way either now.
There's a good mushroom over here, but I don't think...
Maybe this way?
Wait, we can climb from there, right?
How did that work?
Come back, sorry.
I was getting more tea too.
Welcome back.
Are you good?
Yeah.
What kind of tea did you get?
Yeah, what kind of tea?
Snuffy, could you give me a hand up?
Thanks again, Mai-cha.
Um, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Look at you guys.
You're almost there.
Are you?
Wow.
I think so.
We're making progress.
Go through the water.
You just jump out into the abyss?
Yeah.
Watch your stuff.
Don't let it fall.
I like how every time someone in this game dies, they immediately become like, I don't know, the Call of the Void or some shit.
Call of the Void?
A carrot!
Do you need medicine?
No.
Oh, thank you.
You are such a feeder.
No!
Don't say it like that!
I'm just concerned.
Thank you very much.
Wow.
Sharing is caring.
I didn't know you were into that.
No!
She carried the thick mint.
Oh, extra thick.
Thank you.
I got you.
Oh, this is so straightforward.
This is good.
Yeah, this is nice.
Good job.
And all it took was two of our friends fucking dying to get over here.
I was a worthy sacrifice.
I wasn't.
Yeah, you were useless.
My death could have been avoided.
No!
My death could have been avoided!
What are you talking about?
You literally caused it yourself.
There's luggage to your left side.
Left?
Just trying to find a good path.
Do you think we make this vine climb?
I think so.
Vines take...
Vines take way less stamina.
Do you have good stamina?
Do it!
You'll make it.
I think...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Actually...
The fog cometh.
The fog...
Oh, god.
I think I'm gonna make it.
The fog cometh and the fog it taketh.
It does never give us.
You're making it.
You're making it!
And we'll go from here.
Oh.
Oh, god.
And it started raining.
Jump to the...
It's below you here.
Jump here.
Come on.
Do the jump, Snuffy.
Jump so far.
Hold on.
I'm gonna wait for it to stop raining.
Do it, Snuffy.
The fog is coming.
Well, I might join you guys...
Just a moment...
It kind of looks like an easy jump, but I'm afraid I'm gonna be more like an anvil.
Alright, here we go.
The one, the two, the call of the void, the call of the void.
Okay, I broke my chins a little bit.
Snuffy, bring your own down, bring your own down, bring your own down!
Oh my god, thank you.
I thought you were gone, I literally, I think I was in shock for a second.
No, it's still here, it's still here, it's still here!
Okay, the fog, the fog, we gotta go!
Don't leave, we're not gonna make it!
It's gradual damage.
Oh, I can't see because of the fog, this sucks!
You're almost there!
Follow me, follow me!
I think we're under a tree!
No, Snuffy, follow, follow Ivo!
Come, come up this way, come up this way!
Yeah, yeah, follow Ivo!
Oh my god, Snuffy's eating!
To the left, to the left!
Snuffy, to the left, to the left!
Everything you owed in a box to the left!
The tree?
Maybe, I don't have any stamina left.
It's the wrong way!
This way, this way, this way!
Uh-oh!
Oh my god, she's bad!
I did it!
Oh, oh, this is so...
Oh, Snuffy!
Snuffy!
Yes, go, go, die, slipper!
Yes, throw Grunkle off, throw Grunkle off before you die!
Yeah, throw him off, throw Grunkle off!
Oh, that's it, that's it.
Oh, he's slipping, he's slipping.
He's slipping?
No, he's not.
I think we went the right way.
It sucks here.
I think, I think maybe we, we made a wrong turning somewhere.
Uh-oh, wait.
There's still a far ways away too.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
The fog is so fast!
The right way was, I think we were just really slow.
Yeah, we kind of like, meandered around a little bit.
I think the right way was the, the right way.
Ha-ha.
No, no, you can make it.
I think you guys should have grabbed the vine.
I grabbed it, I grabbed it.
It was, no, I think this is a tree.
Oh, no, no, no, different tree, different tree.
Never mind.
It has bees!
There's the bees!
It is a bee tree, but I think it's a different bee tree.
The environment looks different.
Yeah, it does, you're right.
Oh, wait, no!
Isn't that the, the same, that's the same, uh...
That's crazy.
Oh, it's waning.
Did you just say it's waning?
Isn't that the same suitcase from before?
It's waning.
The old man is snoring.
He hit his head.
He went to bed and bumped his head and couldn't get up in the morning.
That's the story of Doki Bird.
Do we need to do a wellness check?
Uh, so I don't have the same drink I had last time to make this.
This is exactly the same clip and I don't have the drink.
Uh oh.
Wait, you have the drink in your backpack?
No, someone swiped it.
Who would have done such a thing?
I don't know.
Don't talk to her.
Like at all?
It was you.
I don't.
You swiped it.
I didn't actually.
I had a water bottle but it was in my backpack.
Uh oh gosh.
Oh gosh.
Oh whoa whoa whoa whoa.
Careful, careful.
Hm.
Whoa whoa whoa.
Alright, since we are all confessing right now.
I may not have been the one that swiped the energy drink.
Oh my god.
The worst kept secret ever.
I mean, I kinda watched you do it.
She was giving you the time to confess and you just...
It was me.
And I did.
And all is forgiven in the eyes of god.
Oh, okay.
You're a ghost.
There is no...
There is no forgiveness.
I just have some unfinished business.
Oh.
Oh, that's a lot of spikes.
Oh, fucking rain, fucking rain, fucking rain, fucking rain.
Um.
If I have my drink, this would be so much easier.
Your character looks so angry as you said.
It's just unfortunate.
I would...
Oh my gosh, you're so close.
Oh, this is fucked.
There's like nothing here.
Oh god.
Yeah, there's a rock.
To the left, there's a little green patch.
Yeah, I see it.
Yeah.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you can grab that.
And then all is forgiven.
Oh, that was so close.
All right.
And then you can grab that.
I don't want to worry you, but the fog cometh.
Okay.
The fog cometh, and the fog can take it.
The fog will take it.
You made it.
Woo!
Yeah!
We did it again!
Oh my god!
See, this is why I feed Limo and she carried us.
Yeah!
Yay!
Oh my god!
We're heroes!
Yay!
Oh my god!
Fuck god!
Do you still have that open?
Yeah, that suitcase is still up there.
Yeah, the suitcase... how do you get that?
I don't know.
You can't climb this, too.
I think it was just generated, like, fucking fucked up.
Yeah.
Moral boost!
I'm cooking.
Wait a minute.
So are you guys gonna see the capybaras this time?
I'm eating.
Oh yeah, I wanna see capybara!
Yeah.
Gotta go fast!
Unfortunately, I have just died, so we don't have Gungle.
Or the trumpet.
No...
Oh, can I cook the herbs?
Herbs?
I wonder where one of them went.
Hmm...
Cute!
I wonder what happened to the other marshmallow, too.
Hmm...
C'mon, Stan.
It's fun.
Nah.
Funny.
I'm climbing.
The freezing airs.
You know what?
By the time I get my...
I got Invisalign in...
By the time I get those out, it's gonna feel weird to have my teeth actually be able to touch each other.
Like, I'm just gonna be uncomfortable and like...
For age or whatever.
What's Invisalign?
It's like braces, but better.
They're like...
A retainer, like...
Slightly less obvious.
Huh?
It's kinda like...
Like it covers your whole mouth, right?
Oh...
It's...
It's like...
It's like a little...
Plastic tray that your teeth...
Like...
Uh...
Sits around your teeth.
It's molded to the shape of your teeth.
Ah...
Is it still cold?
How much to buy your yeast Invisalign?
Yeah, it's still cold.
Oh...
It's cold, it's cold.
It's a lot more expensive than regular braces.
From what I've heard.
It...
Depends.
Like, clear braces.
Yeah...
There's another...
Oh, there's that...
I remember that suitcase.
Depending on the...
Yeah.
I don't think it's even more subtle than normal braces if they put enough attachments in, which I have.
Uh...
What do you mean attachments?
You get like...
Sparkles and like...
No, it's like...
It's like little clear bumps that they attach to your teeth to help the Invisalign anchor to your teeth.
Ooh...
What'd you say?
That sounds so strange.
Can you put like jing on it?
Oh yeah!
I don't know, actually.
Uh oh!
Oh gosh!
Wait!
Oh!
I made it.
This is okay here.
Wait, can we go inside the earth?
It's kind of horrific when you fly off the cave and then it throws you into these like open...
Yeah.
Endless caverns.
Yeah, I wanna ca...
I wanna go...
I wanna...
It's hard time...
Float off a mountain into a cavern!
Yeah, it's our chance to go cave diving for real!
We can really...
We can go cave diving and see it through to the end.
Oh my god, we can finally...
We can cave dive.
That's what I've always wanted.
Executing cave diving.
Mint, did you not cook your marshmallow?
It was you.
She likes it raw.
Oh sorry.
Mint, you totally didn't steal that marshmallow.
No.
It was...
It was you.
Of course.
Who else wanted it have been?
Who else wanted it have been?!
You bastard!
I remembered already.
Why do you think it was gone?
Come close.
It's just us, too.
I'll push you into the storm.
Nobody will see.
Nobody will hear you .
Nobody will hear you scream!
It's like, if a tree falls down an empty forest.
Maya, there has to be more food somewhere.
I think we should go to the way that we were going before Snuffy and I died.
Yeah.
Oh, there's food right here!
Oh, you got some.
That's right.
I got me some oranges.
Some orange guys.
I have a marshmallow.
Although, it's really, I mean...
I have nature to save me.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, no.
That's right.
You can't have it.
Take it from my dead hands.
I'm gonna choke you.
I'm gonna choke you and no one will know!
Fine, take it!
That's right.
I took it.
You didn't take it.
Do you... Did you get the boost from it?
Yeah.
Okay.
It was a... It was a science experiment.
Hello!
Wait, wait, how... Oh!
Don't forget capybaras to the left!
Yeah!
Capybaras right there!
I've seen the capybaras!
I didn't get to see them!
I'm heading over!
Run!
Get there before the storm comes!
I'm running!
Get that mushroom!
Does it affect you when you're in there?
When you're in the storm?
No, it doesn't.
Yeah, as long as you're in the water, you're okay.
Oh, is that them right there?
Oh my god, they're so easy to get there!
Yeah!
Yeah, they're right there!
Oh my god.
I don't wanna... I don't wanna be there with the capybaras.
I'm tired!
Come here!
This way!
I'm so tired!
Hello, little capybaras!
I am here!
I hope they don't touch the lava.
They're... they're awfully close to the lava.
Wait, what's on his head?
Oh my god, they're so cute!
Ooh!
Ooh, eat it!
Just stay in the water!
It doesn't hurt you in here, no.
Oh, oh, oh!
Yay!
Oh, I'm trying to get that!
Oh, ugh!
That Chris Berry!
Yeah!
Why is it purple?
The water is, like, so purple!
Yeah, why is it?
Why is it purple last time?
What the heck?
Maybe... because it's night time.
Maybe the pH level has changed.
Oh yeah, it's reflecting the clouds.
It's so pretty!
The pH levels?
Okay, nerd, shut up!
Yeah, the pH levels are high, because I was in there.
The fog!
The pH levels are high, because I was in there.
You guys, I think we should go to where Snuffy and I were at before.
Yeah, okay.
It's over towards the left.
Yeah.
The other way seemed really difficult.
It was.
What are you guys... cackling about?
Really!
Yeah, I flipped.
Climb my train and take over my bird eggs!
Nothing.
Nothing!
Alright.
Want me to feed you?
We're going, we're going, we're going.
We're going, we're going.
I'm feeding, I'm feeding.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
So full!
Oh, you were watching, didn't you?
I don't know what I was watching!
What?
I don't know what I was witnessing just then.
Did someone have the other heal root, perhaps?
I need it.
What happened to you?
I don't have it.
I have this, is this what you wanted?
Yeah, could you feed it to me?
I fell on my butt, please.
Get in, get in!
Please feed me the root, Ducky.
Thank you.
You did it.
I don't have any fucking pride.
Oh, nice jump.
Whoa, parkour!
Parkour!
Stop!
Get out of my way!
Get out of my head!
Come on!
This is, we're gonna require ultimate team work together.
Yeah.
I don't remember even where me and Mint were.
It was like, I don't remember either, actually.
Is this the right way?
I mean, it looks pretty good, honestly.
I have no idea.
I go by based on fields and vibes.
I don't need a map or a compass.
I got vibes.
My body tells me this is the right way.
I'm coming.
The wind is blowing.
I can smell it.
Thank you.
Go here?
Where are you going?
I have no idea.
I'm going.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm going down.
Also, is the implication that the Scoutmaster is actually a psychopath and has put us through this trial on purpose because the campfire set up with marshmallows at the top every time?
Well, when you told me that he comes and attacks us, I was like...
Wait, what?
Aren't we, like...
Aren't we on an airplane crash?
So does he have the anti-air or some shit that blew up our plane?
We...
Yeah, we could have.
We could have been saved this whole time.
Yeah.
Scoutmaster wants this for us.
Wait, he attacks us?
Yeah.
He has anti-air.
If you climb ahead of your friends, which is why I was waiting for Snuffy on the last map, if you climb too far ahead, he spawns and, like, throws you off the mountain.
What?
Wait, I kind of want to see it.
He's just waiting for it to happen, yeah.
Oh, this is safe.
We can all just leave Doki behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm literally right here.
Being left behind doesn't make him show up.
Oh.
That's it.
I'm angry.
Leaving...
Leaving others behind in your solo.
Eating your anger away?
Are you...
There's actually so much food on this mountain.
Holy crap.
You're not you when you're hungry.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Maybe up here?
Oh, left or right?
I think that's more than right.
Oh, I see a suitcase down there.
I see a suitcase down there.
Yeah, I see a suitcase there too, but is it worth it?
I don't know.
There's nowhere to go left.
I think that that much is clear.
Maybe, can we climb this tree and jump to here?
That seems kind of fucked.
Do it!
Oh, there's a thugish down there.
This is my calling!
I'm trying!
Oh!
So, uh, that tree doesn't appear to have a hip box.
She's okay.
I don't think we can grab that.
The branches, you cannot grab, guys.
I just wanna let you know.
You can.
You cannot grab.
Wait, so we can't touch the pretty blue crystal either?
They turn, they freeze you.
Oh.
Oh, so what do we do?
We just go down?
I mean, you can touch them briefly.
Does anyone have rope?
Like, don't we have a chaingun or something?
You could chaingun to here.
I don't think anyone grabbed the chaingun.
What?
How did nobody grab the chaingun?
I didn't.
Where was the chaingun?
It was in the last, in the last map, I thought.
Nobody grabbed it.
I don't have it on my backpack.
I didn't see it.
Go ahead.
I saw it, but I thought someone with a backpack was gonna grab it.
Maybe that was the last one, but it's misremembered.
Yeah, there's two people with backpacks, and that's not us, Doki.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, it's not us.
It's not our fault.
Whatever.
No.
I think we're gonna have to go back down.
Wait, I have a shelf thing.
Will that help?
Maybe?
Yeah, maybe we could shelf that.
Oh, wait, wait.
That's the shelf.
I can...
Don't worry, I'm a M-M-M-M-G.
Okay, okay.
I'm watching, I'm watching.
Watch this.
Oh!
Very good.
Yeah, and then we grab there and then we get over there.
Right?
Huh?
Wait, I found the chain launcher.
I thought we were going up here.
Oh, we have a chain launcher.
Oh, you found the chain launcher.
Yeah, I have a chain launcher.
Okay, maybe we go to the shelves and then go there.
Either way, I think we want this.
Want what?
What?
What do we want?
Okay.
We want to go here.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can do it, Snuffy.
Snuffy, Snuffy, Snuffy.
Wait, what if I go really, really far?
Wait, I kind of...
Wait, this might be...
Don't be...
Hold on.
Wait, what are we doing?
She's experimenting.
I think she might...
Oh, nice.
I put it a little higher.
Look at her go.
Oh, that's such a fucking bad timing for the storm.
Oh, take it easy, guys.
Oh, oh, thanks.
Wait, how do I get off this thing?
Get me off...
In quest space.
Just wildly rad.
Okay.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming over, too.
I kind of got fucked because I had to jump off the shelter, so I might be scared.
If I could put it some way that, like, you could jump off here.
Can we even climb up that?
No, you can climb up that?
I think I'm fucked.
Wait, no!
No, wait.
I have rope.
Okay.
That would be cool.
Just be careful.
There's lava.
I'm gonna check that suitcase.
Watch out.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm not gonna check the suitcase.
Can you see the rope, Wymou?
I can, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna put it...
I'm huddled, I'm huddled.
Oh, ouchy, ouchy.
I'm like a penguin.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Yeah, yeah, I hope that's enough.
Why does the lava not keep us warm, you know?
I think it does a little bit.
Okay, it's gone.
We're good.
Okay.
I'm going for the suitcase.
You were too late.
Oh, it's a lantern.
Trail mix!
Does the lantern keep us hot?
I don't know.
It does, yes.
How do we go up?
What are those?
What is that thing?
Oh, that's the thing that flashbangs Snuffy.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
Lava.
I think you can come up this way.
Uh-oh.
You can come straight up here.
Yeah, I'm going to wait.
Give me your hat!
Oh, look, you mean...
I'm a little peckish.
Oh, yes, yummy!
Thank you!
You enjoyed all of feeding.
Oh, yeah, this is how we do it.
This is going pretty good!
Oh, man!
Come on, come on!
No!
I lost...
Go straight, straight up this way.
Straight up this way instead.
Okay.
I lost all my extra energy.
No!
Oh!
What the?
Thank you.
Okay, there we go.
Come back up, Snuffy.
I got you.
The music.
Thank you.
We're going, we're going.
We're going here.
Yeah.
And then...
How did you get all the way up there?
I just did.
Oh, wait.
There's a little spot here.
Just keep climbing.
There's a little tiny...
Oh, God.
The lava.
Oh, the lava.
Don't touch the lava.
It's a little spicy.
That's what the sound it makes when you touch it.
I think...
I don't know where to go after this.
I'm going to wait for Snuff Master Llama.
I think we might actually want to go, like, around this way?
Yeah, it's not here.
You see this little bit here?
No.
There.
Oh, that seems kind of hard.
How are you going to get there with Llama?
Yeah.
I don't know.
How is it looking that way?
Is it okay?
Um...
It...
It's good.
I think it's better.
It's better.
Okay.
Let's go this way, then.
I think it looks...
A little bit easier.
Although, how do we get up that first part there?
A tree?
Is that crazy?
Oh, there's actually a huge jump, though.
Oh, there's some fruit.
Oh.
I'll try.
I feel like this one might actually be more straightforward.
If you can get across there, and then you go up here, and then up here.
I would watch you guys demonstrate.
Okay.
I mean, you could maybe use the tree.
I don't know.
Wait, but there's a luggage over there.
Yeah.
I want that.
Oh, that's a huge fucking jump, though.
We have another rope.
It's not that big of a jump.
Use your...
Gamer legs.
Gamer legs?
Oh.
Yeah.
What do we do?
It's a jump master.
I'm yum yum.
Oh.
I'm yum yum yum yum yum.
Who's hungry?
Anybody?
I'm good.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah.
We go over there.
To the right side.
That's really far.
There's no way.
Yeah, it's so far.
Where else we go?
I'm gonna try the jump.
Oh my gosh.
She's doing it.
Do your best.
Oh my god.
Scout master.
Scout master did it.
Scout master!
She's a scout master.
It's not too bad.
You can like...
This is strangers.
Okay.
Alright, go snum.
I've got...
I got my arm up for you.
Jump, yeah.
I don't have a ton of stamina.
Wow!
Scout master did it!
I'm so proud of you.
Oh my god!
I'm gaming!
Ma!
Get the cat!
Hooray!
We made it!
Yeah, we're here for the storm.
Don't touch this rock.
Don't touch the rock.
Don't touch the boot.
They're very freezy.
It's a dangerous rock.
I'm touching it.
There's some food above us as well for those who don't have stamina.
Is it a safe place?
It's red food, so it's nice.
And a suitcase.
I love it this way.
It's like a little cave in here.
Oh, we're going the other way.
Are you diving?
I know.
Wait, now can you stick out your hand?
Because I might fall.
What if we were caved?
Okay.
I'm okay.
You're great.
You're doing wonderful.
I'm doing so well.
Here we go after that.
There's some food and there's a tree if you want any.
See?
No.
It's too far.
Snum.
The job for snum.
Who's the one that always climbs the trees?
It's snum.
Hey, where do we go after this?
Anybody need any food?
Oh, let's see.
I'm okay.
This is good.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Thanks a lot.
I can put my arm up for you.
Wow.
You're welcome.
Wait, that one was all me.
I'm glad I was very helpful.
Wait, why do I...
Why can't I stand?
I got you.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Huddle, huddle, huddle.
I'm cold, I'm cold.
I'm cold.
I feel so cold.
Snubby's got a lantern.
You're cool, you're cool.
I'm not cold.
I got her somewhere.
I feel cold.
Hey, no, you're so cool.
Is she fitting?
Are we all fitting on here somehow?
We're here, we're here, we're all.
Alrighty.
Alright.
Onwards and upwards, gang.
Is that any good?
Yeah, I don't like this eye.
Yeah.
Oh, not, not yeah.
Not yeah.
There is...
Oh, Jesus.
There's this bit here?
If we can jump across the lava behind Mint.
Oh.
But it's still really far.
Wait.
It's still really far.
Oh.
What about to our left?
That's like really far.
Hmm.
Anything over that way?
Actually, yeah.
I wonder if I eat, if I can make it up there.
Okay.
I'm gonna try.
No, you, you...
I don't...
I don't think so, Mint.
Careful.
Is that safe?
Oh.
Why am I poisoned?
Uh oh.
Come this way, Mint.
You got it.
This is safe.
Bye!
Thank you.
Min, come this way.
Uh, which...
Oh?
Where?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there's a safe, there's a safe.
Oh no.
Come on out.
Min, are you okay?
Can you see my room?
Yeah.
Wait, how do I get to there?
Is it?
I'm good.
It doesn't come in.
I need an extra.
Just a little bit of stamina to get back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're fine.
You got it.
Guys, I don't think I'll have enough stamina.
It was a green berry?
It looked like an apple to me.
I'm trying to look at you.
I'm dealing.
Come here.
I need to go out here.
Where?
Where's here?
Where are you?
Come here.
Oh, I see you?
I need some damage.
I'm so cold.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm okay now.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready to grab you.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to get up.
Oh, no, my lantern!
Oh, I could've...
Ouch, this took more damage.
No, the lantern!
Give me a sec, I need to recharge my stamina.
The lantern!
I think I need to grab it.
Can you get up here, Min?
Okay.
Um...
I don't think so.
Alright, I'm coming up.
From the tree, maybe?
Let's try it.
I'm coming up.
I do.
You do?
I'm coming.
Sorry, there was no room for me down here to put this, but...
Snuffy, if you can climb up here, I got the...
I gotta...
What is this?
Oh my god!
I'm so...
Okay.
I can help you too, so hopefully together we can come back up.
She's a team player!
Snuffy!
Snuffy the goat!
Wait, how do I...
We're coming!
Crap!
Oh my gosh, I got the rope!
Oh.
Ouch.
Snuggle.
Snuggling.
Cuddling.
Guys, guys!
Are you guys...
Are you guys here?
We're running out of time.
Yeah, yeah, I'm here.
What's happening?
Where?
Where did you guys go?
Right here.
Right here, right above you.
Oh.
Grab my hand!
I'm here!
Thanks.
Grab my hand!
I almost didn't make it.
There you go.
Yeah, we live!
We did it, guys!
Lots of food in this tree up here.
Yes!
Oh, uh-oh.
Huddle, huddle!
This is not ideal.
This is pretty bad, actually.
Huddling, huddling!
Stay here!
It doesn't hit here, too.
We're good here, too.
It's good here, too.
Get off of us, Stokey.
Wait, no, wait.
No, you guys can crouch boost me!
Crouch boost?
You can, actually.
If you jump on...
If you jump on each other's heads, you can just jump.
Boost Joby!
Go!
How many people can be on a baton?
What?
For those rusty ones, I don't think you can both do it.
Nope.
Don't try!
Why didn't you...
How did you not make it?
Wait, I thought your energy...
I thought your energy comes back after.
I thought so, too.
You have to hold on to it for a little bit.
I don't care about those special ones.
Oh!
Aww!
He has, like, so confused.
Oh, oh, oh!
That- That funny!
You hold your head out!
Nope.
Nope for me.
That's right.
That's right!
Well, some of us...
Oh, my god!
Look at that frog!
Okay, I think I can...
Oh, god.
I think I can eat and maybe lift this up.
She's gone.
I eat.
Wait, this doesn't give you energy at all.
Like the...
Oh, it does.
Wait, this is bugged up.
Now it did.
Oh, weird.
Wait, so you're good now?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's good.
Okay, I'll wait.
How are you not dying to the storm?
I got you.
I'm coming the same way as Doki!
Reach!
Oh, it collapsed!
It broke!
This fat ass is kept getting fed by everybody, and that's why it collapsed!
That's the fat.
It could not carry Doki Bird.
Ugh!
Okay, I try...
No!
Alive!
I'm sorry, it was a problem.
Ah!
Stop!
Reach out!
Help!
No!
I tried...
I tried to grab you.
It's okay.
Okay.
My hand.
Oh my god.
We're so close.
Why are you leaving us?
That's not true.
I don't see if my hand was out.
No, it wasn't.
I took the hand, that's all.
There we go.
Sorry, I didn't know she was doing that.
What did I do?
I think we go up here.
We're going up this way.
What the fuck did I do?
What do you really know I was doing?
What did I even do?
I don't even know what I was doing.
You're doing nothing.
That's the issue.
Dude, there's so much blue rock.
This is so sick.
How did you even time that?
Does it freeze kill you?
I'm so tempted to touch it.
It's a little freeze like the snow.
The same as the blizzard.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I don't understand.
I can't get on top of that.
I don't know.
How come I let her on top of that?
This rock?
Right here?
See you with you.
I'm on top.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
No, no, no.
See, I told you.
I'll push you off the lead.
Oh, oh, please.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You took me down with you.
There's a baton here.
Uh oh.
Wait, I don't understand.
I can't see the...
You can do it.
Skill issue.
Did you get on it?
Oh my god, you're pushing me off.
You're pushing me.
I'm on the now.
You're pushing me off.
Wait for three!
I'm on the now.
Yay!
It makes the dream work.
Where do we go now, Scoutmaster?
I'm taking a look, hold on.
She's taking a look.
We're going to take a look too.
I'm taking a piss.
At this whole situation... My god!
My god!
She's dead.
She's super dead.
She's so far beyond dead.
She's dead.
Did you push her down?
I got you.
Where's Mim?
She fell horribly far.
She's far from God.
She is dead.
She like ricocheted so bad.
I don't even know what's happened.
Oh, there I am.
I'm beneath.
Oh, gosh.
She was threatening you, but I think she was talking about Mint falling.
Hi!
Oh, hey!
Yeah, I died.
I fell, and then I ricocheted, and then I...
Oh, no.
How did you die?
I fell, and then I, you know.
How did you fall?
I don't think she had enough stamina.
Yeah, I didn't have enough stamina.
Oh.
You should have said, I had a little berry.
I would have given it to you.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I wouldn't have given it to you, but I had it.
Yeah, I know you.
Whatever.
Wait, my arm is up here.
I'm here.
Hello.
We made it!
Wait, really?
Where is it?
We made it!
Wait, really?
Where is it?
Just up here, I think.
Oh my god, we made it!
I was so close.
We're gamers!
You practically are still here!
Yeah, so true!
So true!
I was... I was.
At least we didn't have the heartbreak of using Bongo again.
Yeah, here it is.
Because we already lost him.
Yeah, we lost that guy.
Yeah, somebody dropped him.
I wonder who.
Wait, what?
I think it was actually me!
Yay!
We did it!
We lord of the prizes!
Bring me back!
Somebody!
Bringing you back!
Thank you!
I'm back!
I'll
put some stuff off.
Are you gonna take the backpack?
I don't trust you if you put stuff in my backpack.
Yeah, well...
Did you take my marshmallow too, huh?
There was only two marshmallows.
What?
Why?
Not even for me!
I don't know why.
Yeah, there's only two.
Snuffy, do you need food?
I need food, yeah.
I have a little orange berry, I suppose.
Are you sure?
Because I'm fine, so if you need food.
I have snacks.
Wait, Snuffy, look in my backpack.
I have snacks in there.
Oh!
Oh, I'm taking your snacks.
Snack pack.
Come here!
I only had one snack.
Yeah!
Snack of snacks.
Okay, so this one is actually fully horizontal.
You see where the smoke is?
We gotta just navigate the lava...
Navigate the lava field.
Oh, wow.
Snack break.
Snack.
At least there's no blizzard now.
It's just lava.
Wait, but I can see the...
The fire.
The campfire.
Yeah, it's horizontal.
Yeah, it's...
You don't really go up on this one.
Oh, it's parkour!
It's literally parkour.
It's American Ninja Warrior.
Yeah, yeah.
Ninja Warrior.
Uh, I think we go left.
Okay.
Left?
This way?
Well, actually, that one's kinda far.
I don't know.
No, we kinda have to go this way, I think.
Oh.
I'm already committed.
Like this way, and then across here.
Okay.
Cause I don't think...
I mean, unless we take a little bit of toasty damage there.
What would you guys like to do?
Toast!
I would look in the stealth master level.
Oh, Christ.
Okay.
Uh, I'm...
What is she doing?
Oh, she's gone.
Oh, she's already gone.
Alright.
Uh, is there any trees in this...
Oh, shoot!
Ouch!
I'm fine!
Well...
I'm fine as a...
Don't forget!
Oh my gosh, Mintz!
If you turn around and grab the wall, you can slide down.
Yeah, I didn't think I was gonna fall.
You hurt!
You hurt so bad!
Oh my god!
What is this pillar of flame?
Whoa!
Yeah, these are scary.
I'm guessing there's no food in this area.
Uh, there are, like, bird eggs around.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, nice.
Yep.
I'm gonna die.
So with this one, you will sometimes take fire damage, but it, like, cools off.
Nice.
Is that the right way to go?
This is the only way.
This is actually my favorite map.
I like this one a lot.
Rest.
There we go.
Go.
You're not clackward.
It's just parkour.
Oh, I don't have enough stamina!
Ah!
Thank you.
It's okay, we'll grip you.
We'll grip you for me.
Please carry me.
Princess, carry me the whole way.
Please.
Don't forget to slide down.
Alright.
What do we do here?
Oh!
Wait, I didn't see what out...
What's this way?
The chain?
Yeah, you can climb the chain.
Just be careful.
If it's low, you might take fire damage.
Fire damage is okay.
It wears off.
I'm about to die.
Come on.
Oh, please.
Oh, I can't grip!
I can't grip!
Oh, gosh!
They're nice and warm.
Oh, I'm gonna die!
I can't...
I have no stamina!
No, no, no, no!
I have...
I needed food!
But don't...
Nobody would give me food!
I think Snuffy just panic-tossed her backpack into the lava.
But that's okay.
That might happen.
What happened to her backpack?
I didn't have a backpack.
Did I?
I don't think so.
I got everything from my backpack.
Yay!
It's this way.
It's this way, Snuffy.
This way.
What?
Snuffy, turn around.
I don't...
You say this way, I don't even see you guys.
I don't know what you mean.
I'm alive!
You okay?
I have...
Does anyone have food?
Because I'm not gonna make it.
I don't have any food.
I do.
You need to get over here though.
Okay.
I have food too.
Look at my nice water.
Just wash for those.
Wait, I'm letting the fire go down so I have more stamina.
You can go first.
I'm literally...
This is gonna make me touch lava.
That was killing me.
Oh!
I'm dead.
GG!
No!
Snuffy!
Ouch!
I pressed E!
I should have thumbs up.
Do do do do do do.
Do do do do do do do.
Why are you doing this?
You can't feel it.
Oh, it's because I have the stamina.
Oh, that's why.
I had to leave, though.
I was getting burned.
I had to.
You could have waited.
Waited for what?
No.
I'm defending my honor.
Waited for what?
I was literally on fire.
I was waiting for the lava to cool the
high tide.
Oh, I didn't know that.
What do you mean?
I
didn't actually know that either.
I didn't know it goes up and down.
Yeah, it goes down.
I saw you guys.
I was like, oh, well, they made it.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I saw the lava go up.
Well, how were we supposed to see it?
I was literally dead.
Look at your eyes.
The eyes tell you.
We'll have to wait for this one.
I think it's about to catch fire.
I'm rooting for your death, Doki.
In fact, I'm going to block your vision the entire time.
Yeah, you wish you had this lollipop.
I don't care about your fucking lollipop.
You still have that.
Min's was literally begging for anybody to feed her so she could make it.
I know.
And you wouldn't feed me.
No, I was like, I was like, wait, if you make it here, I can give you this lolly, this marshmallow.
You didn't say that shit.
Yes, I did.
I have this marshmallow that I can give you.
Oh, the marshmallow that you stole because Snuffy and I didn't get one?
Oh, I got there before you.
I was dead.
I was dead!
Well, too bad.
I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill you again.
You won't.
Come on.
Why aren't you going?
Baby Doki, come on.
Look.
I just think it catches on fire.
Look how fast!
Look how fast Laimoo is going to get pushed off the mountain from the guy.
No, she's because you're so slow.
No, I'm waiting for it.
Look, look, it's going to catch up.
Oh my gosh.
That's going to catch on fire.
That's because you took too long and the god is angry.
No, it's fine.
No, it's not.
Yes, it is.
It's fine.
I'm going to wait until this catches on fire.
I don't think it will.
Yes, it will.
I feel like Doki is literally on fire.
Oh wow, that's really on fire.
Are you okay, Laimoo?
The whole fucking thing is catching fire.
Is Doki going to make it?
Will it stop being on fire?
I don't know.
She was so busy arguing with you, she didn't move.
I know.
I kept telling her to go.
Okay, stop being on fire.
Death.
Holy shit.
Are you guys good?
That's a fucking deed in here.
Death, die, die, die.
I wonder if that was what she was shouting.
Death, death.
Even though her death wasn't even my fault.
I was starving.
I needed energy and I had none and nobody gave me any.
I nearly said, hey, if you make it through, if you make it, I can give you my mind spell.
I needed it before then.
That's what I said.
I needed it to make it through.
I did not know you needed it before.
Death, die, die, death, death, die.
You have to give her the lollipop though.
She would rather die than give her the lollipop.
It worked.
Oh, you should have just waited until it receded.
Oh, Doki, why didn't you wait?
Doki, you were going down.
Yeah, why didn't you wait until the lava went down?
Doki.
Gosh, Doki.
Do you see the face I'm making right now?
Yeah, I do.
It's so good.
Ow!
Maybe because like someone kept yelling, die, die, die, die.
That was a fake connection through the lava.
That was clearly not...
You shouldn't... What do you mean?
You're supposed to use your eyes and wait for it to go back down.
What?
You didn't know?
I said it.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
It worked.
You manifested the downfall of a fellow scout member.
I hope you get a badge.
I'm pretty sure... Is that going to actually like catch on fire?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I think it's just because it's high right now.
Yeah.
Nice.
You can just climb up.
Climb, climb, climb, climb, climb.
Oh, now you're not going to say die.
Yay!
It's called being a team player.
Oh, yeah.
You're the best team player out there.
That's for sure.
Literally, you are definitely not rooting for anybody's demise.
No!
I'm rooting for Lymu all the way.
Yay!
Teamwork!
Supportive friends!
There's only three marshmallows.
No, there's four.
There... I can see them with my eyes!
Die, die, die.
Die, die.
Welcome back.
Thanks.
Time to make...
Quickly take all the loot before Doki eats it all.
I know.
Look what I got, guys.
Oh, my God.
You got it back.
Never.
Never punished.
I got my lollipop back.
Wait.
Oh, I want this instead.
No lollipop.
No lollipop for you.
Look, the lollipop got res too, guys.
Oh, wait.
I can just do this.
Do we have any climbing items?
Does anyone have a sports drink?
I have rope and...
Oh, I don't have sports drink.
I have an energy drink.
Oh, there's one.
Hold on.
That's an energy drink.
That's all I have.
Oh, just kidding.
That's kind of what I wanted.
Sorry.
I meant an energy drink.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's...
I'm ready.
We're going into the depths of hell.
Let's go.
Let's go into the hall.
Steps of hell.
Yeah.
Hooray.
I hope Scout Master is smiling down upon us.
I hope Scout Master is going to be so proud of us.
You look so proud, Laimu.
Oh, uh-oh.
My game lagged.
Oh gosh.
Let's go.
Oh yeah, no, don't say that.
This area is laggy as hell.
What?!
Yeah!
You have to pay the troll toll to get inside the boys' hole.
What?
I don't think anybody has ever said that to me, but you just said it in tandem.
Oh, you never heard of the critically acclaimed musical?
Dayman!
Ahhhh!
AAAAAH!
FIGHTER OF THE NIGHT NOW CHAMPION OF THE SUN HE IS THE PROTECTOR OF FRIENDSHYPING TO EVERYONE
This is the last map.
Can you imagine if you guys finished Peak on your second run-through ever?
Oh my god.
That would be crazy.
Wait, I'm scared.
Don't jinx it.
I want to live.
I'll be good.
I swear.
The killin'?
The killin'.
You mean killin'?
You say that again?
I thought it was like, I'm killin' you.
Killin' it.
And now it really begins.
The killin'.
The left looks kinda weird.
What's the gimmick here?
Is it also catch on fire?
No, it's just hard.
Like, the pathway that it gives you is hard and sometimes it's like...
You can't really do it very well without items.
Okay.
Yeah, you can run out of items to climb this.
We're just following line.
Yeah, so it's kind of like more of a, did you do well the rest of the game check?
Which, uh...
That scares me.
If I die... the Lollipop dies with me.
Wait, where did... where did Limeo go?
You okay?
Yeah, we're just looking at the different...
paths.
I don't know where she went.
She's behind us.
She's right here.
Thank you.
Okay.
Wait, how did you get up there?
Actually, I don't know at all.
I don't know.
Okay.
I'm just by... I'm just going by by.
Oh, she's going.
It's a little bumpy, but I guess we can just...
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Thank you.
You got it?
Okay.
Here.
I'm here.
Nice.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Where are we going now?
I think up here, maybe?
This way?
Okay.
We're going up, up, up, up, up, baby.
Oh.
Oh, you're good.
Right side looks like it gets openings that we won't be able to cross.
It's hard.
Yeah.
This is crazy.
If you've seen a good pathway, let me know, Snuffy.
Oh my gosh.
If you look.
I don't even know what a pathway is.
I think it's mostly the left.
It has a lot of good laying.
But the right area is just like empty darkness.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Well, I almost didn't make that.
Oh, thank you.
I think so.
So the other thing about the kiln is because there's no food in here, you kind of just need to like.
Oh.
Book it a little bit.
Okay.
Going up.
I think we need to get to here somehow.
Yeah.
Going up.
She going up.
It did not work out.
Oh.
It does not look good though.
I'm grabbing you.
You okay, Snuffy?
I caught you.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you too.
Okay.
I got her more.
Yeah.
You can stop here.
For, for...
Stamina.
Yay.
Okay.
There's a place here too.
I'm here.
I think this place amplifies the sound of my growling stomach.
Oh, thanks.
Oh, are you hungry?
I'm a little hungry.
Oh, crap!
Uh, a little bit stuck.
A little bit stuck.
Oh gosh.
There's so many of us here.
Thank you.
I don't pull you guys out.
Come on.
Doki!
Oh no.
Doki merged with the wall.
Wait.
What's going on?
What?
Doki, you need to separate from that surface a little bit.
So try and drop down a little, then come back up.
You're stuck in the wall.
Come on, Doki.
We're out of rush.
We gotta get up there.
Oh no.
She's just panicking.
Stop showing off, Doki.
Come on.
I can't get out!
Water!
Pull!
You guys gotta pull!
Your limit's stuck in the wall.
You gotta move away from the whole thing if you can.
Like, drop down a bit.
Is it fully gone?
I don't know.
Are you good now?
Am I?
Are you good?
You look better.
That looks better.
Am I better now?
Yeah.
Try to come back up now.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh no.
Do you have any items you can pick up?
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Do you have an item?
Hold an item, it should fix you.
Hold an item, it'll fix you!
Okay, okay.
Oh wait, how did you get up there?
Okay.
Am I okay?
No.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Oh, this catches on fire.
Oh my gosh.
Sting!
What did you do to me?
I don't know.
Guys!
Dogey, have you ever seen the movie 127 Hours?
Oh look, you picked yourself, good job.
Oh my god, you made it!
There's like...
Is there anything up here?
So I think we're gonna have to try our best to climb on each other's heads and get up here maybe.
Oh.
Or we take a very big leap over there.
Don't trust me.
Don't get on my head, get on my head.
That is a big one, that is a really big one.
Get on my head.
Oh my lollipop.
Wait, wait, why don't we just jump here?
Which one?
Whoa.
This way.
That's what I said.
It is kind of big though, so it'd be kind of scary.
You'd have to like climb on this, I think, as a midway point.
And then scale around.
It's hot too, so you're gonna take fire damage.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared, I don't think I'm gonna make that.
Oh my gosh, she gained!
We're cool, we're cool!
Did you sprint for...
I did a lunge, but be careful if you don't have enough stamina.
Oh!
You might be able to stand on top of this actually, but it's hot.
Follow me!
You're good, I got you, I got you.
I think you can stand on top of this, just run.
The damage will fade away.
I'm gonna eat.
I got some rope too, in case we ever need it.
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
Just jump off and on here.
There you go, you're fine.
Yay!
Hooray!
I don't know where to go now.
Up here, I guess.
What's like the goal to get to?
The top.
There's actually an opening.
The top of the hole.
Oh, there is?
Yeah.
Oh.
I don't know how we're gonna get up from here though.
No, me either.
I don't, I really don't think there's like a way to go.
But we can't really go down, cause we're losing stamina.
I have cookies.
I just, I think...
Oh gosh.
How did you guys get up there?
Wait, how are we here?
There's two cookies in here.
Yeah, there are.
We don't have any items, I assume.
No.
How do you get up there?
Here, I'll boost you.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm climbing.
Oh, thank you.
I got you.
Thanks.
Oh, nope.
You got your own.
You're all good.
Oh, maybe we have to go through here.
If we, if we even get up there though, how do we get up here?
We, I don't think we can.
Oh my god.
It's too high.
The only other place that looks...
I don't even know actually.
I know it.
I fucking made this place.
Is that like a chain launcher?
Nothing looks feasible right now.
We, we could, we could go all the way around here, maybe.
Oh.
But, I don't, I think, I think we need an item.
There's items in there.
Does anyone have anything?
I have rope.
We need to get up to use rope.
Doesn't the lollipop make you go TD fast over here?
It does, but only you.
Okay, Doki, hear me out.
Hear me out.
I think I know what we could do.
But, you should take the lollipop, and you should go up here.
You should use that energy to climb all the way up to this bridge.
Yeah.
And try and get those loggages.
Do you think it would work?
Do you think that's enough of a boost?
Well, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's your time to shine.
No, no, hold on.
No, take this rope.
This is your lollipop.
Take this rope and lower it down for us.
No, no, no, no.
No, it's not.
You should do it.
You should.
Well, I'm actually, I'm actually looking at this.
Look at this.
If we run across the hot rocks, we can actually get all the way up there.
Awww.
That's what I said before.
Oh, okay.
A hot rocks.
We can try that then.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we're going back down?
I think so.
Where we came from?
Okay.
Oh.
Man.
That's gonna hurt.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's gonna hurt.
I gonna leave a mic.
Can we get up there?
But it's on its work.
Okay.
You don't, you only take like a tick if you're quick.
This one's okay.
Oh, gosh.
I'm not fast.
I took a lot more than a tick.
I almost died.
Be careful, guys.
Be careful.
Oh.
Okay.
I got it just a little bit.
Thank you.
Come on, doggy.
Okay.
Oh.
It's spicy.
There we go.
I'm gonna wait here and give you a lift up.
Boy, this is scary.
Uh-huh.
Thank you.
Yep.
Music.
Oh, my gosh.
Alrighty.
Okay.
So across the big rock and onto the bridge.
You see what I mean?
You should go first.
Okay.
I know what you mean, but you should go first.
Oh, God.
This is gonna be beans, actually.
Oh,
why is the music so intense?
I don't know.
Okay.
That is...
Maybe?
Oh, my God.
She's aiming.
Oh, what does she do?
What does she do?
I didn't make it.
I didn't jump.
I'm going back.
Grab me.
I'm scared.
I took it out.
Somebody else go.
Is that enough rope?
If you can get to this bit, is that enough work for you to get up?
I think so.
Sure.
Yeah.
You can even put up a little bit more.
Any good?
A little bit more.
That's about as much as I can do, apparently.
No no no, pull it back up a little bit.
Okay, a little bit, a little bit...
Still more, still more, still more.
Okay, that's good, that's good.
If that saves us any extra rope, I'll take it.
I have rope too, so...
Okay.
Selfie, I believe.
Wait, no, no, no, this isn't the way, this isn't the way.
Take me, take me.
I take my body again.
Guys, I have my feet cooked.
I don't know if I can make this jump.
Alright, I believe, man.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh crap, crap, crap, crap, crap, crap, crap, ee, ee, ee.
Okay.
I almost didn't make that.
Guys, that was really bad.
You're okay.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
I got my hand out.
Oh my god.
I made it.
We're fine.
You made it.
I made it.
I think... do you think we go across enough?
Or do we stay here?
I think we might stay here.
Snuffy?
Oh no.
I don't think Stuffy...
I don't think Stuffy made it.
Okay, we gotta keep going.
Oh, can I have one?
Yeah, I need some food.
Okay, thank you.
There we go.
Oh gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I get up this way, I think.
There was some medkits and lollipop.
And a lollipop, sorry.
Yay!
I'm a big boy now.
Hey!
I don't know if this is the way though, because it gets very sheer again.
I'm wondering if we go across.
Mmm.
Oh.
Like, both ways suck.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't think this goes...
Oh, Stuffy, what happened, Stuffy?
Stuffy!
Unless I can get up this way.
I knew I wasn't going to be able to do it.
No.
Lamo, you sacrificed yourself for us.
No, Stuffy!
You guys made it!
There's more luggage on the other side.
There's more luggage.
I think we go this way again.
I think so too.
So I think we...
You purposely didn't tell us that you were starving so we could safely...
Ouch!
I didn't think I was that low.
I thought I had good stamina.
I was...
I don't know.
Oh no, Mint!
We're going across.
Yeah, we're going across.
It's okay.
I took damage, but it's okay.
I'm scared, guys.
It is a little scary.
Yeah.
Do you think we do the Hot Rock?
Or do we go on the right?
I think the Hot Rock actually...
There's a bit above it.
So I think we need to do the Hot Rock again.
Ouch!
We'll be able to stomach standing on the Rock.
She's so injured.
Ouch!
Wait, are you actually injured or just hot?
I'm injured.
She broke our legs.
Yeah.
Oh.
Ouch!
Thank you!
Ouchie, ouch!
Wait, you should save it!
Oh, thank you!
It's fine.
Ouchie!
What do we do?
It's spicy here.
Uh...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go check.
Okay, I'm...
I'm going back down.
Ouch!
Come down!
My spicy legs.
Doki, come down here so you don't get hurt.
No, it's fine.
I'm safe here.
Oh, okay.
You are?
Ow!
Yeah.
I'm safe in this little hole.
Oh, okay.
I'll come to the hole.
Nice.
There's a spot to stand.
It's bucky though.
Okay.
How bucky.
Yeah, you can stand.
Yeah, wherever you are.
And then you come up this hot rock here.
Ouch.
Guys, I like stand.
You can't fly.
Ouch.
Oh god.
She's burning up!
You can do it!
Thank you!
Woo!
That was...
I'm just gonna check the suitcases.
Can you wait for Doki?
Yeah, I'm looking out for her.
That was spicy.
Okay, who's starving to death?
Um...
I'm hungry, but...
You know...
I think we're probably all the same amount of hungry.
I'm not gonna lie.
No, I think Mint you needed a lot more.
Oh.
I mean, I have rope.
Do we put more food in me so I can rope for Mint?
Or do we try and keep Mint slightly higher?
Mint has rope.
How did you make this?
How did I...
Uh, with...
I don't know.
With a...
With a dream.
There's a spot to stand on the hot rock.
Yeah, there it is.
Yeah, there you go.
No, it's not.
It's not it.
Oh wait, there it is.
Yeah, yeah.
You just gotta catch it.
Grab my hand!
Wait, wait.
Oh, you can?
Okay, hold on.
Um...
I'm going to eat this.
Mint...
My chat tells me that if I knock you out with a blowgun and you sleep safely, you won't be hungry anymore.
Come over here.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We have a...
Mint's lowest.
Come here, Mint.
Okay.
Put yourself in this corner.
Put yourself here.
Knock me out.
Honk.
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm sleeping.
Go to sleep.
I'll see you in a minute.
Good night.
Oh, wow.
Can I pick her up or something?
What if I pick her up and chuck her into it a lot?
Uh, pick her up for a little bit.
Just pick her up and hold her for a little bit just in case.
I don't know if it like causes a problem.
Um, it says that I'm about to die, so...
Did you guys unironically play with motion blur?
What's wrong with you people?
Wait, I have motion blur on?
Did you not?
I feel like you did.
Do I?
Did I?
Did I actually put motion blur on?
Oh, they can't hear me, that's right.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I think as long as they hold me...
There's no motion blur anywhere.
I'm awake!
I think?
Good morning!
Are you hungry anymore?
I'm not!
Hooray!
I'm letting the Z's go away and then I'll be okay.
Okay.
I almost...
If Doki...
Also, if Doki hadn't picked me up, I would have died, so...
Oh.
I'm super...
It's like we're just looking at your body for the longest time.
Okay, I'm just...
I'm catching...
I'm recovering.
I think another hot rock jump is in order.
It's pretty slow, but I'm almost there.
Yeah, there's also this part here.
How you doing, Snuffy?
What?
I'm chilling in this...
Chamberlain.
Let me have a look.
Pop box.
Alright.
Pop pop pop.
Oh shoot.
I need to...
Pop pop pop pop.
Oh gosh.
Oh!
I'm waiting for...
Laimu's executive...
Decision.
Okay.
Oof!
Okay, yeah.
There's lots of places to stay here.
Okay.
I'm following you, Doki.
Wherever...
Laimu went.
I didn't really...
I didn't really know what she did.
But okay.
Alright.
You're okay.
You'll see it.
It's pretty straight forward actually.
Oh, I see it.
Nice.
Yeah.
And then...
Left side.
Over there.
Turn around.
Oh, here?
Oh, I see it.
You got it?
Wait, why am I...
Why am I attached to the wall?
What the heck?
I was gonna get you, but...
I got it.
Okay.
Wait, did you...
How did you make that?
Uh...
Climbed up this way.
I'll put my arm up for you.
Okay.
I got you.
Thank you.
There we go.
Maxer!
Yeah!
Yeah.
Oh my God!
How much further?
Oh wait, I think I see the ceiling.
We're almost there, we're almost there.
Where are we?
We're actually almost there.
I see the light!
I see the light.
Following limelight.
The light, it calls for me!
Do you want to go straight to the light?
Yeah!
Go to the light!
Yay!
Oh, okay.
There's a spot to stand just below me.
You're good.
Sorry.
Sorry to push you.
You're fine.
Okay.
Behind you.
There you are.
Here?
Oh my gosh.
I think so.
You guys, we can see.
Oh god.
Don't forget you still have your hunger.
Don't slap off.
Yeah.
I'm so hungry.
I'm hungry.
Okay.
I think we need to go across the hot rock because we could go up here, but there's nowhere from there to go.
I did lose my rope, I think, from the thing.
Oh.
I should have dropped it.
That's okay.
I don't know if we can do this.
Let me do a quick check.
Okay.
It looks like you can stand there where you're going.
I don't know if we can do this.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
To the left, maybe?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's so far.
Shit.
I don't think she's gonna make it, guys.
If you... Uh... Uh, no.
She's not in this way.
No.
It's not that way, so she'll come back to come down.
I made it, but it took up too much.
I think you guys could be on, maybe, the left side here.
These rocks.
This formation over here.
No.
Oh, that way.
Yeah, here.
You might be able to get more footing there without having to go so long between your stamina.
Yeah, look over here.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Got you.
Yay.
I got my arm out.
I don't know if I can make it.
I don't know if we can do it.
I'm hungry so bad now.
Come on.
Oh.
Yeah.
Just made that.
Oh my God.
Just barely.
Okay, Doki, you're going into a ma... Well, actually, you...
I don't think you have anywhere to go from there.
That's probably bad.
I'm gonna be fine.
Sorry, hold on.
You're fine.
Explore all year.
Yeah.
There's nowhere to go.
Doki, don't go up there.
You're gonna fall and die.
It's okay.
I know.
It's kind of fun to grab you.
Oh.
We grabbed each other.
We're here.
It's truly nowhere to go.
You'll have to see if you grab one of his hand up there.
Where is she, though?
I mean, I'm here, but there's nowhere really up here.
That's the problem.
There's nowhere up here.
No.
What do we do?
What about here?
Oh, come on.
Is there anything here?
Where?
I mean, you can go that way, but I don't see where you go from around.
Oh.
Oh, I have the lollipop, but I'm scared.
I think... Doki, I think if you took the lollipop...
If you climbed up there and then took the lollipop, you could probably make it to that bridge, but you wouldn't have to let yourself take a break at all.
You'd have to go straight there.
But it... it'll make you tired, but your stamina will go crazy and it'll be really fast.
I'm going to use the lollipop again.
Hold on.
Okay, well, we'll let her use the lollipop first.
Yeah.
Oh my god, look at your ghost.
She's like a little spider monkey.
Whoa, she's zooming.
I think the eyes are just going crazy.
Oh, she made it.
I think she made it.
Oh, there's a chain gun.
It's actually a rope cannon, less good.
Less good old thing.
She can still use it to make you guys get up somewhere, though, maybe, hopefully.
Oh my god, there's a little hole here.
I scared the shit out of me.
I could have disappeared.
Do I maybe use the... Where do I go?
Where do I lower the rope from?
Like, where would be best to pick you guys up?
I don't even know how... I think, like, Min and I are fucked.
Okay, this is... I see it, I see it.
Okay, I think...
I don't know.
We're getting hungry.
The only place that they can reach that, I think, from where you are, is that second bottom line.
There's some bridge that's not all the way connected to the wall, but it's beneath this bridge.
They might be able to jump on that, but it would be in...
Can you get to this, maybe?
To that?
Okay, we'll get back there.
Let me think, let me think, though.
I can't, I can't drop, because I won't be able to get back up.
I have a lollipop.
Desperate times.
I can try and get there.
Or do you want to shoot the rope first?
Well, wait, hold on, let me try and get above you.
One sec.
Do I use my lollipop now?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh gosh, your eyes are going into the back of your head.
Wait, I'm gonna try and get above you.
She's having a vision!
I'm having a vision, I'm gonna do it.
What do you see, Raven?
What do you see?
No, no, don't do it, don't do it!
Are you ready?
I'm gonna do it.
Don't do it, we don't know where to go yet!
Wait, just make it to the bridge, Doki!
Go straight for the bridge!
What's the bridge?
You're probably abandoning Mint, but...
Yeah, that's fine.
It's not like I've helped you out or anything.
Truck picking you up.
One of us has to...
Wait, do I take the lollipop and go this way?
The right side or the left side?
You have to go right side and climb up the bridge.
That's the only way to go.
This way?
Go where?
Can you see the road?
Yeah, we see it!
No.
We see it, but there was no way we're getting that road.
Hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
So do I go...
Okay.
Stuffy, do I go this way?
Oh, no, no, no.
You would go...
You would go this way, I think.
Either up to this legend when you eat the lollipop and go to the bridge.
I think you go this way.
Or you just go straight up where Doki went.
Sayonara.
I'll try.
There she goes.
I'll stay with you, it's okay.
I'll go when she goes.
Is there anywhere up there to sand?
Yeah.
Can you...
Is the road any better from here or no good?
A little bit, actually.
That's not terrible.
Sayonara!
Doki!
Did you even eat the lollipop?
I did, but it's...
I had so little...
Doki!
Oh my god.
You should've given it to me.
Oh my god!
Um...
Can I...
I could rope cannon.
I can't see any rope.
Hmm...
I'm gonna burn, guys.
Oh!
Um...
How's that rope, Min?
It's like so...
Small!
Wait, I see you!
Wait, wait, wait!
I...
Come back!
Down a little bit more?
You think so?
Yeah.
There's like a...
There's one on your left that's meant there.
It's not on the fire rack.
It's over here.
I thought the lollipop would give me a little bit of...
Like...
Food.
Oh...
You know, you would think that it would do that, right?
Yeah, Min, give me your hand.
Min, is this okay?
I don't know.
I'm...
Oh!
Come on, come on!
Come on!
Yeah!
Okay.
Well, we're now just trapped up here together.
Yeah, we're now just trapped.
Hold on, watch this.
I feel like you're still alive!
With...
with...
Nene.
Rannah, you have some sort of special main character like, immunity in this game.
You keep falling and living.
Ummm...
No, uh, we're not gonna...
Nene, why do you have the stamina?
Nene, .
Nene, and I are gonna jump off!
Just, keep up her!
Wait, we are?
We're gonna jump off.
We're gonna jump off like me.
So the scoutmaster...
The scoutmaster will kill her.
Oh, that's right!
The scoutmaster will kill you!
Okay.
We're gonna do it!
We are going to sacrifice ourselves for you!
Shit.
My friend.
She has to make it.
I'm so hungry now.
I don't know if I can do it.
No, she waited so long.
It's all up to you, Laibu.
It's all up to you.
Laibu!
You're so close!
Oh my gosh, it's right there!
It's right there!
It's literally right there, Laibu!
I can't quite reach it.
Oh my gosh, she's sleeping!
She's sleeping!
I'm okay.
Use the rope cannon!
Use the rope gun!
Wait, there's a luggage right behind you!
Yeah, I want to go for the luggage instead, but...
I don't know if it's... I don't know...
I couldn't get up there.
Okay.
And someone said, drop the spool!
It'll make you less...
heavy.
Your stamina is pretty insane.
The rope.
It's time.
You can't wait too long!
Okay.
It makes you a little lighter.
Maybe?
I... I need... I can get water in my pack, but I can't...
There's nowhere to safely put the pack down.
It sucks.
Let's go to that bridge.
You have to go to that bridge.
I don't think I'd make that.
I would use the gun.
You got it?
Oh my gosh.
Gamer.
Oh my gosh, she's gaming?
Suck on the ledge.
Don't get stuck on the ledge.
Okay.
Nice!
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
She's gaming!
What if she misses this jump?
That would be pretty cool.
Don't shut up!
Don't say that.
Oh my god.
I can hear birds!
I can hear!
Oh my god.
An energy drink?
There's rope cannon.
Rope cannon it from there.
Yeah, rope cannon it.
Where the... like here?
Here.
Uh, hold on.
The left side looks like the...
I...
I think the weird like...
There's a whole lot of pressure here.
Holy shit.
I know!
My god!
Shoot it right in the little like...
Balls right there.
The what?
The phallic looking rock formation I think is your best...
You don't have time to think too much.
Oh, I see the balls!
I think I get what you mean.
Yeah.
Don't shoot too far because of the...
The length of the rope.
Like that you mean?
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Oh, nice!
It's a very short rope.
Right on the balls.
That's exactly what I was saying.
See how it's phallic?
I'm saying this.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
She's literally right there.
She's so jealous.
I can hear...
I can hear freedom.
I can hear the birds.
You think she'll remember...
I can see fresh air!
Oh my god!
It's so beautiful outside.
You're gonna see it too!
Don't fall, don't fall!
That would've been so funny.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared for her.
I can't handle this pressure.
You get it!
You literally couldn't take it!
You jumped the...
You gotta sacrifice yourself!
We had to!
So she could go!
So she could continue forward!
We're now...
Straight up?
There's a ledge right above you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here.
Right here where I am.
Make sure to like visit our graves every year.
Okay.
Well your graves are on the mountain.
I'll have to climb again.
You're a pro!
You've beat this game before!
Oh my gosh.
To the right?
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Oh.
Don't accidentally use your extra energy.
Yeah, I'm trying not to.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, it's really right there.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
I see the sky!
The sun!
The smoke though!
The smoke for the campfire!
Oh my god!
It's like the whole world is at campfire!
It's on fire!
This needs like some epic music I fear.
I know it does actually.
It's like the sky.
The sky is on fire.
Oh my god.
I see it!
Oh my god!
It's there!
Are those the poisonous ones?
It's so beautiful!
Look at all the flowers!
Are those poison?
I can't eat the mint.
What is it?
You should drink your energy drink right before.
A little bit of zoomies right at the top.
Yeah, get a little bit of zoomies before you make it.
I can't believe it, guys.
Look, our second try playing Peak and we finished the game.
I know.
We're so good at this.
We're crazy.
You guys were amazing.
We're crazy good at Peak, guys.
Yeah!
I do think that you guys sacrificing yourselves and having that bravery would got us this win, dude.
If you tried...
I wouldn't have left you if you hadn't jumped.
Let's go, man.
We did it.
Yeah, we did it.
Woo!
Oh my god, his lab will come in too!
Yeah!
Oh, it's so epic looking.
Help us here!
Pequod coming in high!
Yeah!
Scoutmaster!
We did it!
Sir, please!
I'm starving to death!
Why is it a countdown?
One, six, five, four, three, two, one!
Oh!
One!
Have a friend escape the island without you!
Participation back!
Yeah!
Woo!
We did it!
Wow, we did it!
Look at all the times we died.
Yeah.
Here's our badge for dying five times.
A greater challenge?
Are you kidding me?
Oh, I got promoted!
I got tadpole scout!
Oh my god, wait.
New hat!
Sense and add modifiers that make something more difficult.
Tadpole scout!
Oh, I didn't get to see you.
Bye!
Goodbye!
We did it!
We did it, everyone!
We beat Peek!
Woo!
Yeah!
I actually would not have that money on us doing that, like, immediately.
Holy cow!
Oh my god, we made it!
Guys, we carried!
We're home!
We carried, guys!
We did!
We did such a good job!
I never wanna fly again!
Yeah!
Like, maybe you don't ever go back to a fucking airport after that.
Dogpile online, Moo!
Dogpile online!
Thank you so much, everybody!
We did it!
Look at that!
Now I'm happy!
Now you're happy!
Oh my gosh, you're happy then!
Woo!
Sadness cured!
Yes!
And we fixed depression!
What we had to do was touch grass and lava and snow!
Well, I can't believe the Scoutmaster was right!
And, like, climbing a mountain and almost dying and actually dying would fix depression!
Yeah!
They were right!
Just go outside, clearly!
Just go outside, everybody!
Someone superchatted and said, Laimu was the great Sherpa!
Beverly was Everest!
She was the...
Yeah, she was the Sherpa!
We were the rich folks that kept dying on the mountain!
We were the rich Sherpa!
Trying to...
The rich folks driving Everest!
On the Sherpa!
Like, put us on their back to carry us up the mountain!
We did it, guys!
Oh my god!
Thank you, everyone!
I'm so happy!
Aloha, everyone!
Aloha!
You look like you're ready to go on vacation!
Yeah!
I'm ready to go!
Why did you pass out?
Oh, yeah!
Hey!
That was fun!
Thanks for carrying us live here!
No!
Thank you!
It was your first time!
You guys did great!
You did so good!
You're right, Mint!
You know what?
You're right!
We did so good, Mint!
For our second time!
For our second time ever playing!
You did!
You were awesome!
Yeah!
I did 24 runs to ever finish it even!
So that was really good!
Yeah!
And Limo did it all while sleep deprived!
Yes!
Yeah!
That's true!
I'm sleep deprived, but I also have adrenaline, so my body is like, what the fuck am I doing?!
Yeah!
We got the hat!
Sacrificing herself so she wouldn't worry us!
Yeah, yeah!
I didn't want to be averted on you guys!
I was trying to motivate you, you know?
Yeah, yeah!
Fly on your own, you know?
Taking off the training wheels!
I knew you didn't have enough, but you didn't let us know!
Yeah!
You were like, don't worry guys!
I'll be right behind you!
And then you sacrifice yourself!
Just don't look back!
Thank you so much everybody!
I had an amazing time!
It was always wonderful with the sloppies!
Thank you!
Sloppies!
Wait, wait!
Snuffy, are you continuing to stream?
Snuffy, are you still going?
I wasn't...
You were streaming?
Okay, okay!
I was gonna raid, but...
And they still are on YouTube, so I can't raid them!
But I love you guys!
Thank you so much everyone!
Don't do what's wrong with your arm!
Oh!
Sloppy power!
Yes!
What's wrong with your arm power!
2!
1!
Sloppy!
Good night everybody!
Good night!
Bye-bye!
GG!
She left the expedition...
Oh!
It's just us!
What's wrong with your arm?
What do you mean?
It's my arm!
What's wrong with it?
Wait, come look in the mirror.
Okay, what's wrong with it?
Ever since I merged into the mountain...
See how mine is straight?
Wait, I don't see that...
What's wrong?
Oh, mine's a little curved.
A little?
Yeah.
Wait, no, I think it's whatever's on your screen.
It looks weird, but mine's like normal.
It's really...
She shot it.
She shot it, I need to see.
Okay.
Aloha.
This is what it looks like to me.
Okay, I want to know what this looks like.
I'm confused.
Oh my god!
I think it's a broken arm.
I think so.
Ever since I merged with the mountain, things have not been the same for me.
Yeah, it tends to do that.
Alright, GG.
GG.
Okay, GG.
Bye-bye.
I'm gonna choke you.
Oh.
Well, I didn't have to choke her.
She died all on her own.
Wait.
I'll return.
Bing Bong is divorced!
No!
Why?
Wow!
That's one hell of a fact.
I hope you guys enjoyed that.
That was a pretty fun run, I'd say.
Bye.
I'm happy to have collabed with the sloppy sisters again.
I'm sad that I couldn't get the...
The...
What's it called?
Um...
The...
Badge for the...
For the bugle at the capybara.
But it's okay.
It's fine.
I was, like, holding off on watching any peek streams.
So I was like, well...
We're gonna be playing it, so...
That was peek.
Weenie, thank you for the gift.
Thank you guys for all the super chats and...
Don't knows while playing.
Sorry that I couldn't really...
Acknowledge it.
I love my poisonous ghost Arinto.
I...
I'm always one for...
You know...
I'm more for entertainment than for survival.
Luckily, we had someone like Laimu who's a natural gamer.
Soppy Sisters is a great way to start the weekend.
Yeah!
Ghost Poison type.
But I...
I tried...
We tried towards the end.
It was just really difficult.
I think...
I think had I known...
The way that Laimu was going...
I might have been able to make it.
But maybe not at the end-to-end.
I don't think.
I think I would have been too hungry.
Thanks for the streaming though!
It was the perfect way to spend my birthday!
Brick!
Happy Birthday!
Haven't laughed that much in a while.
I was literally crying...
Towards the middle.
I was...
I actually was...
Had real tears streaming down my cheeks.
But uh...
Yeah, it was a lot of good fun.
I hope you guys had fun too.
And thanks for hanging out with us!
Thank you, thank you for watching!
I really, really appreciate it!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
And...
I will see you guys when I see you...
NEXT!
I'm still...
What's that sound?
Atsubito!
I'm gonna go...
I'm...
Rest...
Now.
Actually, I have some stuff I need to do.
And then I rest.
Atsubito!
I didn't expect us to play for this long either, so...
But it was a lot of fun!
Atsubito, everybody!
Thank you so much!
Atsubito!
My mic knocked over my...
I had a mug...
That I didn't know was...
It was behind...
Hidden behind my mic.
And it...
Fell over and I thought it busted.
I thought I heard it...
Bust, but...
It's a ghost mug.
And that's one of my favorite mugs.
I didn't want it to break.
We're good.
It's okay.
It has a bunch of ghosts all over it.
And it says...
It's one of my favorite mugs.
It's okay though.
Yeah!
Okay!
Uh, what was I saying?
Uh...
Otsubito.
Otsubito!
Thank you so much for watching!